Chad is running cuz he knows Tommy C's right he was 17 year old
boys.
You know what? I was like willing to look the other way, but
now if Chad runs, I'm going to have to also agree with Tommy
C, okay? I'll defend a who stands up business, but one who runs
away from Tommy C, never. Never. And I don't think you're that
great a debater If you want to get into this debate, I think
it's just You're not a good debater is a fair point, but where
Let's not forget that you got catfished by a 17 year old
Huh? Name your What is your criticism with the Cabin interview?
What is your
How can I have a criticism if I didn't watch it? You saw it,
dude. Okay. Give the stream to Kenny, bro. Give the stream to
Let Kenny take over D'Angelo. And I you think this must be then?
That's right. Queen and Navy you retired. And that's it. He got
me. I guess. I don't know where that came from. Oh, wait a minute.
That came from you.
He He talks about you quite a bit about the William Max stuff.
Uh-huh. Okay. Queen really wants to do this. And you know, I
feel like 27 minutes, we can let Queen have his like W here.
You're interested. Come on. You're interested. Let's come on.
I'm actually I'm actually not. I literally I literally Sorry,
I'm interested in that you're interested and I feel like you'll
actually commentate, you know? I feel like this is this is like
Hey, you you come on the stream and you want to do this. So,
I'm here to watch content with Queen, man, okay?
I see I want to keep that in mind when I go further because I
I smell something.
I smell something from some guy um saying that they would happy
to moderate a debate
debate with me and McBackend. Oh, god. And why me? I'm the only
guy that goofed on his and spiked on his video. I'm not the only
one. Why not Pop Up God? He's got a bigger Oh, I know why.
I know why. And we are seeing this and I saw this in one of my
last videos. Everybody is sick of [__] death of making
some kind of outrageous hit piece, calling somebody a bunch of
names, AND DEMANDING NEW DEBATE. Jay Saws doing this for it was
doing this with Willie Mack, and he's
I told you.
Where's the hit piece?
Where's the YouTube channel for the hit piece? I That's a good
question. I don't know. Wait, I'm sorry. Where's the contest?
Where's the contest?
He also totally makes things up. We just totally make things
up. Has this guy ever By the way, hold on. Hold on. Has this
guy ever watched a stream of mine? Where did this opinion come
from? Where did it come from? Hold on. Hold on. Where did this
opinion come from? I don't believe that Tommy C has ever watched
a single stream of mine. So, where did this uh Where did this
opinion come from? I wonder. Cuz everybody's tired of it. Everybody's
tired. You're sweeper. You're sweeper. You're sweeper. You're
sweeper. Everybody is just sick
So, this guy says that, I just sent him a long lol. And then
he writes back exactly like all these guys. Like just like I
was making fun of McMadd the other day. Oh, I don't think you're
very confident in your position if you don't want to debate.
Now, I'm paraphrasing, of course.
McMadd,
I am ab- I didn't ask Nicholas to debate, by the way. I just
said, "Do you want to chat?"
I I wasn't like coming for Nicholas's head. I was just like,
"Hey, I think you uh misinterpreted some things." And I I misspoke.
Hey, man, I'll I'll take some I was just trying to be nice, man.
That's all I ever try to do. I was just trying to be nice to
people. I just try to be nice to people. That's all. Absolutely
confident from the bottom of my soul that you're
Absolutely. It's not It's not the nothing I got I I don't have
to flinch. All right? I That the big
Absolutely. I It's It's not like, "Oh god, man, I got that wrong."
If you think I got something wrong, feel free to cover it. I've
never claimed anybody, and I never will. You'd have to be just
uploading myself straight up and making money on it for me to
even uh pull some [__] like that. Thankfully, I never
so
this debate stuff. First of all, they're not debates. They're
gotcha they're gotcha classes.
Dude, he gets a lot of views on his videos. Although I guess
this since he's calling out Chud directly, I'm guessing this
video is getting more than He's got a thousand views in 5 hours.
It's pretty good.
Maybe not quite as good with a 50,000 view channel, I guess.
He gets okay views though. Well, Wait. not great, but Look at
the title. I don't trust Chud anymore. Were these guys BFFs?
Chud doesn't like the Well, this is the video we're watching,
Kenny. Are you not looking at the video we're watching? I actually
didn't. I This is what happens when you say one bad thing about
Nicholas De Orio. Tommy C is like, "That's too far. That's too
far. You can't say that about my nephew." even He didn't even
say and this is what I said. I was like, "Bro, Chud takes little
shots at me fairly often. If I If I don't see him watching my
content, I don't take it personally. If I would see him watching
my content, he makes a comment that's negative, I'll go, "Oh,
maybe that's something I should think about." But if Lots of
times and he wasn't doing it with Nicholas, he wasn't even watching
Nicholas's content. He just made a little comment about Nicholas
like like obviously farming the [__] out of Ethan
and taking a side, which like I'm sorry, that's true. He's just
He's just throwing a little jab at you. THROW A JAB BACK. SAY
HE'S BALD. SAY HE LIKES GOCK. Say whatever the
It's not I don't know. It's not complicated. Have you ever been
friends with another dude before? Like
It just happens. Right. I've already experienced them. I've been
a part of them and I'll be perfectly honest with you, there's
some people that I don't like. Who was that guy that screwed
over Jesus? I never never
That was a Jew. Kind of like Queenan. I can see why that's on
his mind. Remember the the Jesus guy who used to do the big Who
was that guy? Oh. out of [__] what? Is he talking
about Judas or He's talking about some streamer or YouTuber.
Talking about streamer. Can't be Can't be Craig. Oh, okay. Okay.
And then you said you said the Jesus I remember him. Yeah, we
Yeah, we said him [__] up. Otherwise known as raglan.
All right, nobody's raglan me not knowing anyway.
Oh, everybody is chat saying Judas too. So, I'm just super sick
of this demand. I let me make this clear. No debates anywhere,
anytime. Go [__] yourself. Make your video. You have
a platform, you have YouTube, it's free if you have a computer.
Uh this guy is really talking. This is actually [__]
up. Maybe he does know something about this. This is actually
This is like a hate crime right here.
All right, no debates. It has nothing to lose to with a a a position
um of discomfort. I I I absolutely and completely comfortable
with saying that a lot of things you said in the beginning of
your video like I criticize people and I love to criticize people
and I'm going to punch up and I'm going to take [__]
from the commentary. This shows totally insecurity to me. So,
what are we going to argue McMadden? Whether you're secure or
not? That's not a position.
That's a statement, an allegation if you if you would, right?
Ryle, if that if that video has to do with Kinetic Hell, I'll
click on this, but I will mock you if that video has to do with
Kinetic Hell. I've already clicked it. Uh-oh.
Jessica Pizzle and Leanna played 2 minutes of his harassment.
You're like
I have a video out there somewhere. Really? Are you What are
you doing in the video? What are you What are you doing in the
video?
Uh Leanna, you have to send it to me. That's it. Uh I'd like
to lick your teeth. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay? You good or can we we can't keep
I mean No, no, keep going. That was just It was just seemed kind
of gross. How are you?
My bad. Sorry, sorry.
Nothing. Just wanted to say you're looking pretty good in 1080p.
Yeah? You like that family?
You want to go to go play some Smash?
Ryle, why Ryle, WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS?
RILE'S GETTING ME RILE has made the whole commentary community
hate me. It's [__] up. I just sit here doing my stream.
I barely talk about this [__] If I say one negative
thing about Nicklas Aurelio, Rile like clips that, puts it in
an intro, attaches 4 hours of unrelated commentary, and gets
all of the commentary people to get mad at me. It's [__]
up. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sounds good. How How old are you? Oh, you
can You make me expose myself again. I'm almost as old as you.
I'm getting framed, okay? I'm getting framed. I didn't even say
Oh, he's Don't worry about it. You're clearly too old. I won't
bother you again. I apologize. Yeah, no, what? No. I actually
You said you wanted to play Smash. I thought you were about uh
17. Okay, let's pretend I'm 17. So, that that that whole 18 15
thing I'll be perfectly honest with you. What the [__]
happened? You like my ass? Natalie, you have to send me your
tits. I'm done. Good. I'm good. We don't need more. We don't
need more of this. Is that Maral?
Oh, it's Aiden. Oh, what's up, man? Oh. Aiden, we're we're watching
the Tommy C
We're getting Tommy. Watching the Tommy C video.
I don't think we've really gotten anywhere yet, so in the opinion.
I It's It's binary. There's no way for you to know. You could
have been totally confident. There's no way for me to know. I'm
not lowering myself to debate that. That's stupid. That's what
Queenin does. That's what Jace TALK DOES.
OH, [__]
IF YOU LIKE THE VIDEO, LIKE THE VIDEO.
YEAH. Tommy won. Yo, like the video. guys are just a bunch of
I'll like the video. Jesus. What do you call them? I always forget
that [__] word for some reason. It's It's It's um
He's talking about Jesus.
I got ones. All right, he's talking about Jesus. I don't know
what he's saying. He's in me. I always get this Is this something
that will not stick in my brain? Can't you say contrarian? Contrarian.
Contrarian malcontent. Oh, no, I'm triggered. I'm triggered now.
Can we stop with the contrarian talk?
We need to ban that word.
Not what contrarian means.
Is it claiming someone is not what contrarian means? No, he thought
Absolutely accurate representation of Queen Man, though. If you're
disagreeing with the with the with the hive mind thing, you're
a contrarian. Yeah. Yeah, he he his claim is he thinks he thinks
someone just merely disagreeing with a popular opinion is is
them being a contrarian. It's obviously like a reference to Queen
Man, right? even It's not even disagreeing with a popular opinion.
It's It's like disagreeing with their opinion. Yeah. It's like
it could be it could be totally unpopular with like a broader
group, but it would because it's not their opinion you're a contrarian.
But but but but doesn't you can't contrarian is an implication
that like you don't even like actually believe in what you're
saying. You're just taking that position because it's not popular.
Aiden would be the actual example of the contrarian here. You
are You are like so bad faith. It's like ridiculous, man.
All right.
All right. All right. He calls everybody a contrarian he can't
defeat in a debate.
Uh-huh. And he you're a contrarian. You
Contrarian to what? Contrarian to what? Getting it on Chud's
stream. Contrarian to this
Okay. Yeah, I'm straight. You know, with the hope with the hope
to getting it on Chud's stream, right? Where he can best case
scenario call you a sweeper. And I know everybody's I didn't
Wait. I didn't get on to I've never tried to get on to Chud's
stream to like do one of these things. What are we But what he
usually does is well, it's a really good video. Don't know if
I agree with it though.
best case scenario is having it being on Chud's stream. My best
case scenario is coming on my stream, but I say Chud's stream
cuz I feel like people will be
you know, open to the idea than the one-on-one.
Yeah. over and over again. I don't know if you guys know this,
but Aiden and Queen Man back in January Oh, there it something
I said I I don't remember exactly, but it had something to do
with Slasher and tried to get Chud to call me out. So, there's
a constant
real video
Would that be Was he talking about how Slasher was like um
like totally making things up about Dr. Disrespect? Yeah, it
would be Dr. Disrespect 100%.
No, what No, what happened was there were out there were allegations
levied against Slasher about the way he behaved with I think
it was Britney Venti or Jess Was it Jessics or Britney Venti?
No, it's Britney Jessics. No, it's wait. No, no, the DMs weren't
the DMs with
so that he could get Britney Britney Venti to had offered so
he offered the job with like the Philadelphia Fusion or something
if he if she would get him Britney Venti's number. Yeah, yeah,
that's what the narrative was, but that's not what actually had
occurred. Okay, so if I remember correctly, they the original
person who posted those DMs had posted them in reverse. So, it
looked like there were the job offer the request came after the
job offer. That's not what happened. He requested if he if they
could hook him up with Britney Venti. Jessics had agreed
and then he made a job a job offer. So, when he was initially
giving the making the request offer it wasn't a job offer anyway.
It was a Sorry. It was a recommend It was saying Yeah, recommend
generic favor.
It was a Yeah, a generic favor offer and then he clarified further
down
um that it was a that he could recommend He's like, "Oh, I've
got I've got you on anything. You miss putting in contact with
someone at this org, I'll do it." That Yeah, career benefit benefit
some sort of career benefit, but the the point being these DMs
were presented in
by Jessics so it looked so it looked like that was like the implied
offer was hanging over his request to talk to to Britney Venti
when when that wasn't true. And everybody ran with these reverse
DMs and and basically perpetuated this false narrative that he
had used that the the offer at some sort said used was strong-armed.
He strong-armed Jessics. Yeah. job offer Yeah, when off from
the truth. When when when the the offer had already been accepted
before the career before the opportunity at some sort of career
benefit was given and he didn't issue a retraction. What was
the difference between these things? Uh I think they can Like
it goes yeah, it goes basically it goes down
Okay, he talked to Venti for me. same day? Yeah, yeah, it's like
you can talk to Venti for me. It's a one conversation. It goes,
"You Can you talk to Venti for me?" She's like um I I'm used
to um She like does like some exasperated face or something [__]
and then he's like uh maybe and then he's like, "Oh, pretty please."
or something [__] And she's like "All right, fine."
He's like, uh "I'm sorry. I don't want to just, you know, put
put you in the middle or something [__] like that."
And then she's like, "It's fine. I'm used to people only talking
to me to get to Britney." And then there's like a winking face
or something [__] like And he's like, "Okay, thank
you so
blah blah blah uh if you need anything, I've got you.
And then yeah, if you need me to link you up with someone in
this org, then I can I can do that. It just goes down like that
basically.
And you brought this up to deflect from the disrespect stuff,
right?
Uh yeah, he started bringing this up to bring slash his credibility
into question and [__] and talking about the how
he can talk about the doctor situation and [__] like
that. That's why I first went to look there.
And just to clarify
I don't expect Tommy to make even though he probably should,
I don't expect him to make a concession
to to Kwebbelkop, right? Cuz there's underlying beef. But I've
always been like completely fair to to Tommy. So the fact that
he saw that saw the criticism and then was unwilling to address
it or at least talk to me about it and he's now acknowledg- He
obviously did see it, but he's now acknowledging he saw it and
never addressed it is like uh kind of funny. Like it's it would
just be a very easy like concession to make. Hey, why you put
this up on stream right now?
Putting what up on stream?
Oh, nothing. Is that Yulio eating a
Why doesn't Yulio like me, guys? Oh, this guy is stuck. Guys
is obsessed. Yeah, this is
Sorry, these people are people in my Discord don't like Nick.
I don't know Um Yeah, people in your Discord They've been spamming
They've been spamming They've been spamming that gift for some
reason and I just thought it'd be funny to have Aiden up there
talking over it. That's all. That's all.
Good one. I thought it was funny. Back to Tommy.
Back to Tommy, Thomas. Good one. Back to
C Nile. Yeah, it was for them to push it up the
to call me out. And chud stays on the fence because he's very
comfortable with the image that chud is fair. Extremely comfortable
with it. And so much that it just at this point it just kind
of seems to me like he's sort of waiting for his moment to say
I don't know the Yulio, but Clemon made a really good video on
you. Whether it's good or not, it just matters how the audience
reacts to it. Does guys realize that like we stream like 8 hours
a day and this is clipping things out of the stream like it's
not like somebody's sitting here putting together a meticulous
video on you. It's literally just sitting here like watching
something. I don't even know what he's talking about.
What he's saying that No, he's saying that
chud is in a Machiavellian manner uh setting up Nick to be betrayed
in some way with with a big project or some [__]
like that from me or someone else around chud. It's going to
backstab Nick and then chud will be like, "Oh, Nick, I don't
know. That made you look That made you look really bad. I've
got I've got to disavow you now because you're you're really
evil." That's basically what he's saying. You know what this
is? He's saying that Tommy C's intentions are pretty good or
Well, that's just not what's happening at all. That is obviously
not chud's intention at all. No, it's not Chad's intention, no.
Tommy comes Sorry, I mean to interrupt you, but Tommy comes from
a community, right? The same community I come from, where people
are just not used to taking jabs at or like
people that they're going to actively consider for like typically
when you're doing something like that, it's bridge burning. You
They're not used to like if Chad's making some massive criticism
against somebody like DiOrIO, like in his in his side of the
community, that's like not typical unless you're burning a bridge
with somebody. Um and they can't fathom like the idea of like
being willing That's the end of the relationship if there's some
kind of disagreement. It's just like that's not how I think Chad
looks at it all. I know I look at it all.
Yeah, so he's taking it to the He's taking it to the extreme
cuz he's applying the standards that he is he thinks are normal
from that side to to this side, when in fact it's like actually
way more normal to be able to like take jabs at and criticize
like your associates when your job is literally to criticize
people for a
Almost like it's healthy.
Yes. Yep. Wow.
Uh yeah, Ralph just sent me a video. I don't know what he's doing
right now, but he sent me a video that is a old one. Tommy C
might have I I wonder if Nick made like a couple comments about
Tommy C. Seemed like Tommy C got really sensitive about it.
Made a video. Hold on. I don't think I'm I'm not listening to
this guy, but uh It's like an old one. the green M&M stuff,
it's just the green M&M stuff, yeah. I don't know what the
[__] that is, but But apparently it's context that's
important. DiOrIO was going through his destiny liberal arc and
Tommy was still a
uh you know, your Fox News watching boomer uncle. So literally
I genuinely think I wouldn't be surprised if it plays into this.
I think Tommy genuinely is like has some
deranged like feelings towards anyone slightly left wing cuz
in in the Dr. Disrespect [__] he was freaking the
[__] out and being like, "Oh, it's a conspiracy cuz
Dr. Disrespect's a right right wing leader. They're trying They're
trying to bring
Dr. Disrespect cuz he's right wing." It's like I I don't think
that's what's happening. I think he's just one of the most sought-after
stories in like years. And yeah. Then then here I don't know.
It just feels like that's the only thing I can think is that
because I don't He's branded me a breadtuber, he thinks that
I want to take him out cuz he's a conservative and and Chud's
take him out cuz he's a conservative, too. I think he watches
Fox. I I've spoken to him extensively. He has like very political
brain, but like to the extent
Yeah, he is like it's a complete hatred for the left.
I Yeah, you and your wife are more of a communist, right? I think
we mean it.
Yeah, this guy like literally was defending Stalin just randomly
in VC sometimes. That wasn't a defense of Okay, I was I was just
You just burst, didn't you? I actually just have a special interest
where you just like stop. Yeah, we were talking about Dust and
Sentry, too. I think you're missing the US is all gets a bad
rap. You know, the Holodomor wasn't intentional. It's not really
a genocide in the way we're talking about genocide. No, it was
No, it was The Holodomor was I remember these exact words. The
Holodomor was absolutely intentional. My argument was that there
that it was not necessarily a genocide because genocide it has
the same effect as a genocide as you're intentionally killing
a bunch of people, but genocide is not has the same effect as
a genocide, so it's kind of a genocide, right? That's not how
that That is not what that means. A genocide is it When we're
using genocide in the context of a mass killing, we're implying
a genocidal intent, right? The purposeful intent attempt to wipe
out a group by virtue of their nationality, ethnicity, religion,
etc. Um so even if it has the end result of a bunch of people
dying, it's still not a genocide if that intent isn't present
under the legal definition of what constitutes a genocide.
Okay. My bad. Sorry.
Yeah, that is your bad. All right. How do you square being like
a like a left-winger communist type and being a Zionist, Hayden?
I'm not a Zionist.
Wait, Hayden or Aiden?
I was I wasn't saying you like Legacy. I'll just say Legacy.
I know you're I know you're Hayden. I know.
I'm good. Can we go back to the video? We're having a good time.
We're having a Now, I don't think that's a very good
I don't think that's a very good friends at all. So, you just
push this thing up and hope Chud says something negative about
it. He usually doesn't, but to me, I don't know if Chud is fair.
I feel like Chud is waiting for his moment. And I was kind of
reminded of that when he said, "I'M CALLING OUT YOU, NICHOLAS
DEORIO."
And then he chew on something Stardust says it. Now, I know he
apologized for it or or got it straight. But, I'm getting to
the point with this and something that was in McMaid's video.
No, Chud viewer? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. And then he put in
something Stardust said? when he said, "I'M CALLING OUT YOU,
NICHOLAS DEORIO."
And then he chew on something Stardust says it. Now, I know he
apologized Um Oh, what was it? Oh, that we're basically JQing
on main now when we talk about We're JQing on main now? For real?
or got it straight. But, I'm getting to Wait, he apologized later
or got it straight? What did did Chud apologize or
Probably to Nack in private.
Wow. Wow. Oh my god. Oh my god. Wow, we're just JQing on main
now. Oh my Oh my god. Okay. All right. Wow. Sure. Okay. Wow.
to the point with this and something that was in McMaid's video
that has made me think for the last couple days that maybe the
meme Chud is fair is not quite accurate. So, let me make my case
to you, right? SO, I'M CALLING OUT YOU, CHAD, AND I PROMISE NOT
TO TIE something that Stardust said and make it about Nicholas
De Orio. I'll just make my case. How about that?
No, I said that I tied things I said to
No, I think he should tie things Stardust said to Chad. I think
that would be funny. You know, we I sign up for that segment.
The mouse kept demanding for debates. I will never do the debates.
I will never go on there again. I got cornered by Kleiman. And
um there's the there also seems to be a power with the test group
that doesn't fly. They come back and go. Have you seen that when
Kleiman went after Kleiman was like bloodthirsty? Okay, but hold
on. Hold on. I totally understand why Tommy might think this
because Chad totally totally totally ratted Tommy C on that.
If I remember correctly If I remember correctly, Chad was like,
"Hey, I've got like a friend named Kleiman. He doesn't necessarily
like have a positive opinion of you. Would you want to talk to
him?" No, Chad is always like he can be a bit much sometimes.
He always says something like that. He always loads he always
poisons the well against me every time. should have poisoned
it more. It wasn't enough poison. No, that's Yeah, there was
not enough poison. You were a bit much. You have to match the
tone It's You have to match the tone of your opponent a little
bit.
It got It was kind of like having a screaming Wait, Tommy started
screaming like immediately in that conversation. Yeah, yeah.
I'm saying Kleiman hated
Kleiman, you cut people off a lot. I think you kind of got under
his skin. I
Hold on. You understand Chad didn't poison it enough. That is
actually the issue is that he did not say this guy like actually
despises you. Is what he should have said. know. I wasn't like,
you know, that like crazy. I don't even like, you know, even
now I still don't even despise him. Like do I despise him? I
don't know. Do I despise me? Like no. Like Is he like
gross and like I look down on this guy for sure, Sorry, go ahead.
You jumped to despise Tommy C. You continue.
Which I I don't really like No, I wouldn't say it's not the same
as people I actually despise. It just doesn't It's not the same.
You mildly dis
Oh, what the [__]
Tectone to my coverage.
Tectone Tectone's commenting.
Tectone's commenting on all of the negative coverage.
Uh unlucky.
I don't know if I got brigaded or something. Apparently got a
bunch of
I'm not good. Not good.
Pull it up. I can't really
I was just informed of this.
I There's a channel that uploads my coverage sometimes. Hold
on.
Let me Let me see if I can remember the name of this channel.
Um So embarrassing to be like over a million having like an anxious
spiral commenting on videos about you.
Yeah, apparently this video got like downvoted to [__]
Which is crazy.
Like most of the coverage I do with like Cherri Kelly, these
videos get like one to 2K views within a day. And this one's
just getting like And I wonder if it's I wonder if it got linked
somewhere cuz
Big Dickey. He just comments on like all of the negative coverage.
It's very
All right.
I didn't know he Interesting. Oh, he just hates you. It's no
problem. Okay, he hates me. Fine. You know. And Then I'm going
to silence for Colonel Michael Robertson, true war hero.
Dirty Mike. W W I and Mike. Let's go.
He hates me. Fine. You know. And then immediate apology like
he didn't know he was going to corner me. Well, I'm pretty sure
he knew that. Um and then it's just
I'm sorry. Chad knew how that conversation was going.
Yeah, but
We how do you real disagreement. Like what what is the problem
with having a disagreement on stream? What what but
Chud's not apologizing, I don't think, for how the conversation
went, really. He's apologizing that Tommy was so unprepared for
it. It's just like, "I'm sorry that you feel bad about it." That's
like I think Chud didn't know here like he didn't know Tommy
was a you I think No, no, no, no, no. No, I think he thought
Tommy knew who Keemstar was, maybe.
Maybe we got No, I feel like he knew Tommy was No, I don't think
he thought he knew I was, but I think I feel like he just thought
that Tommy could handle a disagreement. Tommy was Tommy was alive
at that point. He got Okay, Aiden, if you echo again, I'm going
to lose it with you.
I feel like if Tommy's on LoK Live, like talking to Keemstar
and [__] every week at that point, he should be able
to handle a disagreement on Chud's stream. But he couldn't. He
had to spiral over it.
You do your little tricks. You do your little things.
Do you uh
Do you When he When he responded to you at some point, did you
go, "Hey, are you even listening to me?" I didn't say that. Did
you say something like that? Maybe. I don't know. Yeah, he probably
did. It's just the way he is. Just the way he is. Well, I've
watched Keemstar It's good going on 6 months now. And he's a
dishonest
He's the
Oh, this is the content I like. This is great. We've started
with the canards, have we? You know what? I actually have to
agree. This guy is not an honest actor at all, okay?
He is dishonest. He is dishonest by nature. I'm happy that Tommy's
here to call it out, okay? Thank you, Tommy. He is dishonest
by nature.
The one that's been selling this him and his buddy Jay Starr.
I forgot I was going to clip that, BY THE WAY.
WHY DO I KEEP GETTING LUMPED IN WITH YOU? IT'S SO HE'S DISHONEST,
THOUGH. I should just start going insane because I'm going to
get lumped in with this guy no matter what. I should actually
just start going insane. I should just start going after people.
Cuz me being polite or me being nice doesn't even matter. They
just blame me for what Chud man does anyway. You know what? Never
mind. I Chud didn't know anything. Stop blaming Chud for what
Chud man does, okay? It's [__] up. Yeah, well, that's
true. Yeah, really. Okay, you're talented. That's true. You shouldn't
blame Chud for what I say.
That's true. Yeah. That's what I'm saying. They're blaming me
and I don't like it. And so I I might think that Chud knew what
was going to happen there, but you know what? You can't blame
Chud for that, all
And he's a dishonest player. He's the one that's been selling
this him and his buddy Jay Stalk that with Destiny is kindred,
which is really, I mean, the biggest funniest insult.
I think I think Chud went way further than I did or you did on
that. Wait, Chud. Yeah, wait, Chud. That several thought that
was a sick burn. That big laugh. Well, not even that. Chud literally
like yelled people who came in and were like, "Oh, this like
you're saying this like he literally like screamed at these people
and was like, "Yes, it's far closer to any words you use, you
piece of [__] Go back to your cave. Go back to the
Yeah. Like he he screamed at these people. He he went way further
on that than we did. Yeah, that's actually true. That's actually
facts.
Uh old every victim that ever lived. I also think they're responsible
for
um actually helping Destiny because the allegations are so ridiculous.
I was so
This I don't know why What what with the court case? Why do you
Why do you want to like sell this? I I literally don't blow up
these allegations.
I literally just described them factually. I don't know why I
This is like the most argument.
I don't know No, there's some rhetorical flaws in employed sometimes,
but it's like the idea that Oh, yeah, yeah, helping Destiny.
No, you're That's not how anything works online. You're actually
stupid if you think that that making some argument or some And
then what I mean is you're right. But whether it's whether e-rape
is a fair time like no one cares. If they didn't give a [__]
about the crime they were not even crying but you know what I
mean. They're not going to give a in some case crime actually
but either
they're not going to give a [__] about it either
way. It's like it's not going to be changed by
whether someone is like the whether they watch this and like
it's not going to be changed by whether I'm saying e-
you know.
But it's not even it's oh man.
I think Willy Mac's point in his video is that I said infinite
machine like quoting President Sunday.
I I like what are the they have no actual valid criticisms. It's
just
Okay. Willy Mac shows video. So
I'm sick of it. I think it's weird. I think it's weird to call
out Nick DeOrio. Maybe it was a mistake. I don't
I don't know at all. And here's something else he did. So Queen
Man watches this crazy McBad video which is completely nuts.
Completely I
I don't compare What? genocide and and he's just something that's
saying with genocide
and all this crazy stuff. And he apparently watched this unironically.
Now I didn't watch Queen Man. Did everybody else see that?
Did he actually did Queen Man actually watch that unironically?
Like that guy had a point. It's literally in like like 20 minutes
of I hate you.
You want to tell me how long it takes for somebody to Read the
chat message at the top.
Oh uh Even Charge Logics
Even Charge Logics had mod Stylo King highly malicious also mod
for Queen Man.
Is that one? That's an awesome chat
All right. Are these people
That's some coded nuts. Oh Even Chud Logics had mod Stylo.
Are you [__] It's King Stylo. King Stylo. Highly
malicious also the for Queen Man.
What? What do you What are you asking about, Kenny?
Like you didn't understand that the first read?
Uh no, I didn't.
It's literally the words are out of order. What are you doing?
The Hey, Kenny, the good breaker. I didn't I didn't put together
head mod there right away, not at all. I went for I don't know.
No, I don't know. No, we didn't watch it ironically. Well, I
don't know if that's true or not because he apparently apologized
to Echo
And this is He's I think he's saying I apologized to Nick Cat.
I have not Cuz he apparently apologized to Nick.
Oh, you apologized to Nick for watching the McBad video? I've
literally never apologized to Nick. That's kind of That's kind
of made. Yeah, that's kind of made. I don't know the [__]
And this is not the first time. It just feels like, you know,
you don't have a fundamental understanding. I I I swear to god.
6 months ago, a year ago, I used to be able to argue with people
or watch people on the internet who just like talked about things
that actually happened. And something happened in the last 3
months, people's brains have broken entirely, and they just make
things up whole cloth all the time. It's like everybody's become
They're like realized Bad Empanada was funny, and they all started
stealing the tactics. They're just like, "I'm going to say whatever
I want. I'm going to make up
I I don't know where people pull [__] like this from.
It's very confusing.
Trump, maybe.
I don't know. It's It's just like
I swear to god, last year I talked to people, and they would
say things that were like somewhat grounded in reality. And now
nobody talks
I I don't know what's going on. I Maybe I'm Maybe I'm disconnecting.
Maybe it's me. Maybe I'm going insane. Why Ethan Klein's uh people
don't like these Ethan Klein It just seems like like the situation
with me and um and and immediately Chud shut it down. It just
seems like there's just a constant wave of gotcha. A constant
wave. And I don't know if Chud is just too audience captured
he's snaking people. That's what I don't know. I don't like it.
I haven't heard from Chud in 6 months. Uh Chud is actually, okay,
Stylo and a group of Stylo's friends have Chud like captured
in a basement in America. He's not even in the UK anymore, okay?
Stylo makes Chud go after all these people and snake them. It's
all Stylo. Stylo's running it.
Can I Can I get anyone to disagree here?
I don't disagree with that. What It just hits different for Chud
when Stylo's making death threats in chat, you know? It's like
actionable. So, if if Stylo says go after someone, Chud has to
attack. I think Stylo's innocent. Sure, he's like a teddy bear.
Yeah. Well, he is like one of my best friends, so I really probably
shouldn't talk [__] about him. Uh quickly as well.
Stylo's one of your best friends?
Yeah. And that's uh Didn't you know that? This guy's 800 lbs,
never leaves his house. I feel like you're defending him. never
leaves his house. just don't like that Stylo consistently soycucks
you, and I can go into spicy chat today. The proof that Stylo
and I are best friends is that he's never soycucked me before,
and then he still soycucked me in like 4 months, but talk about
Kenneth Cow, and those guys have been trying to shoehorn me some
kind of inappropriate relationship. They talked about my wife
and how inappropriate Always trying to make me like the tipster
and the goth queen, and Chud entertained it. Pretty unfairly,
I think. And that was also around the same time. And By the way,
you know what Kenneth Cow is? Kenneth Cow is a Patreon that came
to me and asked to do an interview. Somehow that made me a task.
It was unbelievable.
And Chud Going after when she was 14, wow. Yeah, I know. And
I know Chud Wait, did Chud really Did Chud really entertain that?
That sounds like something that he'd be a little hesitant to
go. I feel like he'd go, "I don't know about that."
I think he just looked at him and said, "What are you doing?
You're being weird." or some [__] like that. I can't
remember. Mhm. It was an It was an a Wait, oh, he Is he talking
about the 14-year-old No, he's talking about there was a video
before that of Tommy making advances or something towards the
cat, right? Or like saying Not advances, sorry. Um
peculiar statements. It's the one where he says that he sent
his 14-year-old
Okay, so he's talking Ooh. I feel like, like many of Chud's jokes
about like other people, he probably had somebody in chat say
something, and he probably like read it in like made a joke that
he'd heard in some other chat. That's literally what he does.
You're spot-on. Yeah, exactly what he does. Cuz he does it to
me.
He does it to me. I'm not sitting here getting mad.
That's just Chud. entertain that, but he keeps entertaining this.
And I also sort of feel like Ethan Klein in this situation. If
you're kind of running over those people, you're really not my
friend. You're my critic. And that's fine. We can be critics.
But I don't particularly trust that. And by the way, before you
say I'm a water person It just is This feels revealing to me.
Like, why can't someone be a friend and a critic?
mutually exclusive. You'd probably actually argue in the real
world that you don't have a friend if they can't be a critic.
Yeah, exactly. Should be your biggest critics, right? That's
Yeah, I don't know about like Yeah, I don't even know if it's
like biggest, but absolutely like your friends should be the
people that you're comfortable with criticizing you. They're
the people whose opinions you should seek out for criticism,
right? Yeah. Like that they're actually invested in What I mean
by biggest is like they're the ones who's probably here criticizing
you the most. Yeah, yeah, exactly. I think what he means, and
this is just his cat. I think when he says critic, he's talking
about like somebody who's publicly perpetuating that criticism.
He would probably say like a real friend would come to you behind
the scenes or whatever, but the argument would be the people
that have this like mutual association or involved in a sphere
where their job is to publicly criticize people. So, it is like
by definition sweeping if you're like making an effort to like
hide all the legitimate criticisms against the people you associate
with.
I think if you if you felt like you had a criticism, and you
had like a friend and like co-creator in this space, and you
had like a criticism of them, I feel like it would be good of
you to like give them a message and say like, "Hey, I watched
this. Here's like a heads-up on something I thought." And then
see if they change. And then after that a minor criticism, sure.
If it's a minor criticism, sure.
It's I don't know how major it would no, I I think I think any
um significant criticism you should hash out in public, especially
if it's about people's public statements, because ultimately
yeah, the the the whole thing
you go out on your your platform, you talk to people, you try
and convince someone of what you think. Um if someone else has
a problem with that, that should be corrected publicly, cuz that's
that's the game. That's how it works. I think you can give notice
still. Like kind of like reaching out I think giving notice is
like fine. I think giving notice is fine. It's like the same
concept as asking for comment, right? Yeah, if it's fine, but
it's not required. Or if you want to like saying like, "Oh, if
you want to go on stream and talk about this." or something like
that. You know, that that's perfectly good reasons to reach out,
but I don't think you should settle it in private usually. I
think that's really Uh you don't necessarily have to settle in
private, but here's like a scenario. If you had like a criticism
and it was probably going to cause significant damage to like
one of your friends, I think you could I I would absolutely justify
like, "Hey, I'm going to have to comment on this, but I'll talk
to you first, right? You can give me any context I'm missing,
but I am still going to comment on it." Yeah, yeah, we reaching
out for a comment, but then um the thing is that unless there's
some like super attenuating circumstances, I I hate the idea
that someone gets like some information in private that squashes
it for them, and then they don't say anything in public, and
and that's just like the most annoying [__] in the
world. That's like the most annoying [__] in the
world, maybe.
Um if you want me to use any of the information you gave me,
like then I you you give me the okay to say it publicly, That's
not the scenario Klemmen's talking about though, cuz you're reaching
out to them under the notion that you are at some point going
to be going public about this, right? The the scenario that's
being criticized is the notion of being if it's a major enough
thing that could cause massive harm to them, um that you would
reach out privately, right? That But like Yeah, that's fine.
That's under the assumption Yeah, that's that's under the assumption
we're going to talk about it. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. So, that's
not what's being criticized. Uh no, Brazilian knives, nothing
like that. Not even remotely.
Uh I don't have anything that could like bounce back at me like
that, I don't think. So, I just don't think it's quite the same.
Anyway, I'm trying to do it right now. to handle You are used
to handling your criticisms in private.
Based on your history.
What history is that?
It's a joke.
Oh. Lighten up.
I'll lighten up.
All right. And uh I'm just speaking out of my ass, and this is
a big conspiracy theory. Chud, you can look into it. I'm not
the only one. Hence, why nobody has been on the show that comes
from my community. You know, like Turkey Tom's and
THAT'S OH, [__]
HEY CHUD, you know why none of the commentary people [__]
with you? It's cuz I don't [__] with you. Cuz they
they came from my community. None of these people want to talk
the strings.
None of these people want to talk to Why nobody's gone on there.
You can check into that. You can look into it. Nobody trusts
you. Whether it's just because you're afraid of Queenan,
I don't know.
Or you're a snake and wait for them to hit gold so you can turn
around when the next Nicholas DeOrio video comes out and say,
"Wow, sorry Nick. I know we were friends, but that was a good
video." I don't know if that's your plan, but you run with snakes.
I Why does Tommy C seem so certain that there's going to be a
video dropping on
I don't see how that's so. He can call me a snake. I don't understand
where the snake allegation comes from when I will just say what
I think at every point. Like I don't understand when do I ever
go out and say
"Oh yeah, I don't have a problem with this." when actually I
really have a problem with it.
How is that snaking if you're just like constantly if you if
you say what you
I don't Are you saying Chud runs with snakes?
How would I put this? How could I could I steel man his what
he's feeling here or something? I think it has to do with like
a lot of I think my room is open. Hold on. He's saying somebody
might want to hop on. Are we Are we at capacity or
Who's this anyway?
Okay. So, I could see if I was trying to steel man him, I would
say you've got the spicy audience and you who will kind of like
brew up the best ways to talk somebody. Very good at like finding
people's like weak points and what they're going to get upset
about. And that beyond you, the audience like you'll you'll pull
one of these videos up and you'll like you'll go a certain level
of hard on somebody that maybe is defensible, but then a lot
of your community will be talking to them, will be like uh poking
them and I think a lot of these people can't actually handle
it at all. And they just like fall apart under it,
And I think that's what it feels like is like there's a community
effect behind you that is like your community, Chud's community.
You guys obviously from like the same kind of Genesis point,
right? I understand I understand how it can get on the sunlight
tower. I understand how it told me it gets on Tommy's skin. Like
I get that point. I don't understand the snaking part. It feels
like basically what Tommy's saying is if you associate with people
you should have some level of like loyalty where you don't criticize
them or you don't [__] talk them. But the whole genre
of content you're in is talking and criticizing.
Right? So, it just feels so antithetical to the point of what
you're doing.
Um so, it depends on How would you put this? You could you could
make this argument and I think it's fine. Like I don't I don't
like think you're like a snake or something, but I would say
I understand the people who like Nicholas.
I could totally understand why Nicholas would never want to talk
to like you or Chud. Maybe not Chud. Cuz like he's close with
Chud. He actually shouldn't be such a good guy to Chud. But with
you, right? Because realistically if you have like solid criticism
of him, he's got a lot to lose, right?
Um And he like I'm just saying from a from a from a gain loss
standpoint, um he doesn't have to engage with you,
So he can he can totally like avoid
I I understand like what you're saying profit loss. sure, sure,
sure, sure.
I understand
why someone with a lot to lose would not want to engage with
me for self-preservation or whatever
however, that's not really what TommyC's talking about. He's
talking about like even like associating with someone.
Um and I would even maybe maybe understand that, but it feels
like you know, I've spoken to Nick before and he has he has laid
out the nonsense and tones to me. I don't don't care for you
talk or anything. So it feels weird for Tommy to come in and
call that now snaking when when Nick has laid out very very clearly
that's not
I would just say it's fairly clear and obvious to me that Tommy
does not watch a lot of this content, really. And he could I
think he'll be basing a lot of it on how he feels snaked, right?
Like he feels and I I think there is something somewhat justifiable
there in that I I feel like I knew that you were not a fan of
TommyC when you went and talked to him. Like I I knew that for
a fact. And
yeah, he like looked really bad on Chud's stream. So he feels
like probably being unprepared and somebody comes in and like
makes him look like a and it's a massive like L for him that
he has to hold and you like wrote over him, right? Although I
mean at the time I think Chud had a lot of Nicholas viewers.
They were not happy with you if I remember correctly. No, it
was not like a, know, instant win. The The chat was not super
favorable to you, but I think that was is another thing. He always
like a social climber, not in this one, but he has called me
a social climber before. And it's like a lot of the time when
I have these fights, people are on my side when it happens, you
know? It's It's not like I instantly get this huge wave of sight
on I wait, no, I I persevere and, you know, especially with this
Hassan stuff recently, I even lost a bunch of uh people with
it. So, like, you know, I
It's not like I'm out here just taking like the most optimal
moves every time. I don't think you could ever claim that. Oh,
Chud's chat doesn't hate Quigman anymore. They did not like Quigman
around the Tommy C thing. Chud's chat is way more favorable to
Quigman now, from what I've seen. It's way fewer of the um the
like hardcore commentary because I think Nick I Sorry, I think
Chud doesn't like those people in his room, too. Like the hardcore
commentary sort of like toadies. I don't think any of those people
really I think Chud just calls them like Caraposters. Caraposters.
I don't know what I don't know what you call them, but
yeah. I'm trying to think I don't necessarily think Nick's like
a piece of [__] for not engaging with people who
have criticism, either. If he feels like
uh I don't know how to explain it. If he feels like it's not
coming from a place of like trying to make him better, it's just
like trying to tear him down. Do you know what I mean?
And I think that can be the the feeling that people get with
like the spicy
criticism, I guess. I'm talking about like basically your community,
Chud's community, having to go hard on people. Yeah, your community.
I think I think that's broadly
what I would say is like the steel man, but I I don't know. I
sort of agree with you that there's like a lot of okay, what
what's the actual truth and like what's actually happening here
and it shouldn't be scary to talk about it. But I don't know,
it's it's weird when your income source, when your primary income
source, like I'm pretty sure Nick is doing this full-time now,
right? The the content creation stuff. he's still works at Jump,
I think.
Uh okay. He He definitely gets like uh a lot of content made
now. But in any
um maybe he's just burning the candle at both ends super hard.
but in any case, it's crazy when you have like a huge income
source that's tied to reputation. And like you might have something
that's slightly out of line, but you might think you're like
95% correct. And it's like why would I talk to somebody who's
focusing on that 5% when I can just kind of like clean that up
over time and
yeah, not focus on that.
Like I don't think it's like quite like he feels like he's just
lying and he's avoiding it cuz he's lying and making things up.
I don't think he sees it that way, right? Yeah, you're just describing
a grifter. I don't I think that's how people get down the road
towards grifting. I just don't think Nick's quite there yet.
I think Nick is like sincere in a lot of the things he says.
Um but that's like audience capture and stuff, too, right?
Like he's What is he like quadrupled his audience size in the
past like 3 months?
I feel like he went from like 1,000 to 2,000 viewers to like
consistently 7, 8,000 viewers.
You really think he cared? Yes, I do think he really cared about
the Nazi
And what that could be getting caught up in the moment if like
in the sober light of day, if you wake him up like, you know,
9 months ago and ask him about that Nazi sword, he's probably
not riled up about it. But as he's covered the stuff over time,
he gets into like a mind-state where he's seeing that stuff like
a lot more readily, right? JN can spread the glam.
I'm I'm just explaining to you how like I don't think Nick is
probably I like I I don't know. I don't think anyone's going
to disagree with me. I just don't think he's like an evil grifter
type. I just don't see
Um I think I think it's like you get caught up in this and you
like going in the moment and you're part of a community. And
when you get the massive growth that he's gotten, like it's it's
hard to see through that, okay? It's difficult to see through
that.
Bro, he had a public freak out over a cartoon skull. He is 100%
grifter, mentally ill. I think I think you can get to this place
pretty easily and it's certainly a lot easier to have your mind
changed when I don't know how how much money you guys think he's
making a month off of streaming.
I bet he's making like 30, 40, 50,000 dollars a month off of
streaming. It's hard to say.
You get You guys can all I I feel like this is a What is this?
This is like the Tiger Woods thing where a bunch of people like
judge Tiger Woods for cheating on his wife and it's like, "Bro,
you don't understand the temptation that Tiger Woods has." Like
you don't understand like the temptation. You don't You haven't
put in the work. I don't know. I just don't take the criticism
I take the criticism from Queen it seriously, but a bunch of
chatters who have like never attempted this, never done anything
like this and then they're going to go and be like,
uh Nick is like the worst person." Like I don't think you understand
any the anything that's going on there. I don't think you really
understand it or even come close. He went from like 2K to 5 to
8K average. I I think he's up at like I think he's massive. I
think it's one one to two
one to 1.5 up to like I think he's doing like 6, 7, 8K right
now.
But yeah, I just Okay. The Mr. Lips account, that's got to be
like the old uh the Queen with a Q guy or something, I'm guessing.
Is that a brand new account, brand new follow? Yeah, it's a brand
new follow.
Sorry, buddy. You got to go. I understand I would do exactly
what he did for Queen it. Um I I think it's like the less
I think it's 100% the way to build a brand and to build like
a media empire. I think it's
It sucks, right? It's like the the clearly the the like less
the less understanding, less like morally right way to act there
is just clearly like 100 times more profitable.
And I just don't think most people can make that choice where
they're like, "You know what? I'm going to be totally totally
like morally grounded and I will Bro, all you have to do is get
like a little bit extra angry about a cartoon
and it's like massive viewership. I don't know. He's Actually,
to be honest with you, this whole like kind of rambling thing
I've had about him right now would probably make him more angry
than the actual criticisms cuz I'm like trying to I'm empathizing
with him and he would say, "No, no, no, I'm just totally correct."
100% Like if he ever watches this, this would make him more upset
than anything else that's been said. Can we Can we VIP D. Barama?
This guy's got to be here more often chatting.
Well, I'm just spicy shot. Yeah, not spicy shot. Who is he deep
anyway?
Uh no, it's pretty much just the Yeah. Same criticism I made
of Ethan Klein, by the way. Uh I'm sorry. It's pretty much just
the You run with a lot of snakes and it's starting to seem like
like the kind of criticism you have of them is kind of a bit
of a show. A bit of a show. Don't know. Don't care. Just putting
it out there. You're more than welcome to respond to it the way
you see fit. There's another thing.
Okay, buddy. The um famous New Year's stream and this is the
thing that Chud Logic is literally bad faith. Literally bad faith.
Oh my god. The empathizing would make him
would make him upset as he remembers the patronizing you do after
uh the other half of the time. Oh, maybe. I think you're the
the person who sees that more often, Evil Johnny Bravo. If he
If If he can't see it, it's fine. I'm fine with my audience
I don't need Nick to understand. really bothers me the most.
And this is something I actually picked up when I was watching
um Uh do you all remember the New Year's stream? Remember the
New Year's stream? Yeah. Yeah, it was a interesting stream, uh
to say the least. What were the two What was What was the big
development of the New Year's stream? That Chud pressed both
of them to say that Destiny almost certainly didn't have consent
to send those videos. Hm.
Let me think. Destiny? Uh you know Bobax with the dress, right?
Bobax That's always on your mind, won't Well, this is I don't
I think Chud even knows this.
Nobody, but nobody believe Nobody believes for a minute that
Chud didn't drop that on purpose to create content on a big stream
with big players on the that really what he's saying about? Keep
in Keep this in mind. I knew about the Bowblax dress. Huh. Uh
and some of Bowblax's critics, who had enough respect for him,
kept that quiet, too, including me. And so, what does Chud do?
He brings up the dress out of nowhere. And what's his explanation?
I thought that was already public. I remember his exact quote.
Absolutely nobody believes that wasn't done on purpose. Ooh.
Steak logic giving away Bowblax's uh cross-dressing. Did Bowblax
not make comments about it that were any more obvious than that?
And like his support for non-binary people, people attributed
to his sister. Is that it?
If I was going to If I was going to try and uh imagine
why Chud would have thought it was public, if I I don't know
if I even believe that Chud didn't think it was public. I think
Chud might have been Chud leaking. But, um if I were to totally
still run it, I did say in the conversation with Bowblax, I don't
want to see you wearing the dress. And everyone made a big deal
out of that. So, maybe
he assumed that Nick had said something about it. I don't know.
No. I I think it's a reach cuz I think I explicitly told Chud
it was it was Yeah, yeah. So, I think Chud was Yeah, probably
leaking it, to be honest.
Uh-oh. He's doing like a super big
There's some teeth to Tommy's criticism here, no?
It was like Bowblax to everyone leaked everything on Bowblax,
so I It's just a complaint, to be honest. Didn't Aiden go insane
on him? It wasn't Aiden leaking it like he got infected
I did not leak Like Aiden was trying to Bowblax like actually
become another
Aiden dog story like This story changes every single time you
people tell it. Where's the big bungee video? the facts right.
Is there a Rumble version of the big bungee video? Sorry, keep
going Aiden. I didn't mean to cut you off, buddy.
Chad only reaffirmed things Aiden alluded to, right?
That actually might be true. No. No. I think what I I think what
I No, my statement
that you were referencing Jay stuck was after the dress making.
I had said that he was in some sort of like dispute right now
with his mom. I didn't say that it was a legal dispute because
I didn't know that it was a I didn't know that it was a legal
I only found out that there was a suit involved when I got called
by a certain somebody like
two months ago. I don't know how long ago this was. It was the
same day that Clemon covered it on stream. And they're like,
"Look look what I found in the court documents." And they showed
it to
And that's how I knew that there was like an actual like suit
between two of them occurring. Clemon, do you want to go ahead
and narrate some of the deeper drama comments in the chat for
us? D'Amore in the dress should be like violent when he long
crafts his hands to play brain. That's crazy.
This is why Tommy made this video. brave enough to put on the
dress. Okay. Perhaps he has a whole thing about Nick doing a
cosplay of Raiden from Metal Gear Solid wearing the the skin
tight suit.
Somebody sent me this and said, "This is why Tommy made the video
and mentioned you with Clemon."
Uh what is this? I didn't do [__] This is This is
wrong. That is true. I didn't do [__] Harry Pats.
It was very kind of Chad to rally literally every one of his
fans to harass Nicholas D'Orio on Twitter. That was That was
something that was cool. Hold on, he did do that. I didn't mind
When he was like, all of you guys need That's not my fault. immediately
harassed
Share are people seriously falling for this like bit like
But no, I'm saying Chud called this. Chud said we should do this.
Is that what's happening?
I I mean it's kind of believable, isn't it? So I pray that's
not what's happening. I I just I don't And I quote, Chud said
this on live stream.
I'm jumping the [__] out. I'm jumping the [__]
out. I'm calling Ape Creek. I'm calling Ape Creek already.
He did that. That's exactly how it went. That's crazy.
Oh Jesus, okay. A nice one.
That didn't happen. Now I don't care. It's Bowblax. He's treating
me like he's complete backstabber. He'll say No, I did not. That's
a total lie. I I think everybody's like ah [__] it.
But it did get some people's attention.
It It that was kind of a weird thing to do. And if you really
believe that Chud believes that it was oh I thought it was out
there, then how come there were no videos on Bowblax marrying
Judress between the months of August and early January? I think
that might have got some attention.
I'm just guessing. And you know what? I don't care that he It's
not like
had a Chud had any
Uh everybody was hiding the the Destiny leaks because they didn't
want Pixie Pixie to self-harm. And everybody's hiding the Bowblax
dress thing because they don't want Bowblax to self-harm. That's
crazy. Everything comes back to Destiny with this guy, man. Sorry,
Jerry. True. Obsessed. True. say anything. But everybody pretty
much degree pretty much agreed that mm maybe we shouldn't go
that far if it's just that well, whatever.
But what if I told you, and by the way, uh ZabGaming,
nobody believes he didn't do that on purpose. Chud, check it
into yourself. Talk to people
Unfortunately, Tommy's just kind of spitting out. It sounds like
everybody who's informed is like that. Chud
He obviously did that on purpose, like
We're in the stream. You can check. Nobody bought it. Not for
a second. And it was seems kind of low, but it's Bowblax. He's
a piece of [__] guys, anyway, and would stab us in
the back as soon as look at us. But what if I told you there
was something worse
in that stream? Something that I just noticed when when with
with McMad. And I started to remember on that New YEAR'S OH.
OH. AT ONE point in the Remember when I told you that everybody
knew about Pixie?
Everybody knew. Yeah. Oh, wow. Everybody knew. And this is what
reminded me, and I remember seeing it and thinking it was a little
Everybody knew. All of them. I don't know about Augie and how
much he knew. They all knew it was coming out. Every single one
of them knew it was coming out. I don't know if they knew Oh.
what, where, when, or how, but they knew it was coming out, right?
Okay. particular time, Turkey Tom is still friends with Destiny.
And he's got to keep the rouge up. At this point, no
The rouge up? Is Is Turkey Is Turkey Tom wearing the dress, too?
Why is he rouging up? Knowing damn well when this thing comes
out, he's going to distance himself. Otherwise, who does it tip
off? I think Tom actually distanced himself that this Tommy C
is just kind of up here. I'm pretty sure Turkey Tom wrong all
the time. Yeah, yeah. Like well before that stream. Destiny.
Wasn't Wasn't the whole criticism Wasn't the Craig wrong? Wasn't
the whole criticism on that stream like Tom wasn't really doing
like a super hard like disavow?
Well, no. It was So, no. What happened was wouldn't admit that
it was non-consensual. Go ahead. Sorry, Craig. Yeah, so So, basically
Tom, back when
um the leaks initially happened, distanced himself because he
kept getting called gay. Cuz people thought he was in the leaks.
So Tom couldn't handle being called gay by people on the internet.
So he immediately distanced himself from Destiny. Um and then
by that stream the contention was about calling out the fact
that was plainly non-consensual and he you could probably tell
that from the the public public perspective. Yeah. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Yep. It's incredibly strange that all of a sudden Chud
is putting pressure on Tom and being extraordinarily anti-DGG.
Putting Tom in a really really weird
Now I wonder why Chud would be anti-DGG. Can you guys think of
a reason why he might not like um Destiny or his
I no idea. No no I no idea. No clue. All right. I just wanted
to see if there would be like He's just salty.
Yeah. I just wanted to see if there might be a reason. right
on it because they don't know what's coming out. And remember
when Nick said, you don't know A if this girl's going to change
her mind or B if she's going to get her money. And C, she didn't
want it to come out. That's why Crag and President Sunday are
listed in the lawsuit. You know who's not listed in the lawsuit?
The old school lame commentary guys. Nicholas DeOrio isn't listed
in it. WillyMac's dis not listed in it. No, it's just kind of
the Queenan crowd and the spicy trap chat crowd that are listed
in it. So that to me I don't know what that is. Maybe I know
the Bowblax
Wait. Wait. Wait. All right. Nicholas DeOrio isn't listed in
it. WillyMac's dis
not listed in it. No, it's just kind of the Queenan crowd.
Is he Is he talking about the Pixie lawsuit right now? Sorry,
I missed that. Yeah. Yeah, he is. Okay. And the spicy trap chat
crowd that are listed in it. So that to me I don't know what
that is. Maybe I know the Bowblax is an honest mistake, but that
really really rubs me the wrong way. And it's why I don't really
have anything to do with Chud. It's why nobody goes on Chud anymore.
Cuz we don't know what's true and what isn't. It just seems and
you know you think you see this thing where they're like, "I'm
calling out you, Nicholas DiOrio. I'll I'll and talk about something
DiOrio never talked about like the ADL trying to tie him to that
censorship organization, something that he's never talked about.
I feel like I feel like Shatner is literally just bored, right?
I feel like that was just like him around for fun cuz he was
bored. He was bored all right about that. He got set off by chat
and then he was triggered by that again for Ethan and so on stuff
and um you know, he doesn't want to cover the Ethan and so on
stuff and press up against the huge hive mind constantly.
I think my rate.
Yeah. And joke with these taste men. I'll just I'll just say
I'm pretty sure he was bored and that that's probably just word
for word a rant. He was probably reading his DMs to Kleiman.
That's just a Kleiman rant about I do not talk like that.
It's called this narrative.
I do not do that.
I made that up. I just made that up whole cloth, okay? That was
made up. I I will admit that that was entirely made up. Okay?
Don't actually Yeah. Don't actually do that. Okay? Yeah. Um it
seems kind of shady. Well, he knows it didn't go over that well
because he contacted Nick and he has to talk about
Voice crack.
Who just Was that Kleiman? Yeah, I don't remember him talking
cuz I remember him talking about it. You remember you remember
Okay. Okay. Okay.
Um it seems kind of shady. Well, he knows it didn't go over that
well because he contacted Nick and he has to talk about it.
He's trying to talk about it with me, you know, and get things
straight. You know why he wanted to get things straight? Because
he knew if he made any honest criticism about Ethan Klein it
would be seen as drama.
And he knows it. He could absolutely criticize Ethan Klein for
any wacky thing that he had done and saying no disrespect to
Nick or no disrespect to that. No. You know the one way the wrong
way to do it? I'M CALLING OUT YOU NICHOLAS DEORIO. UH-OH, that
didn't float. Nick, we need to talk about this
Well, I suggested that he not talk about it privately cuz it's
doing one of two things. You're just doing a lame ass temperature
check. It sounds It sounds like Chud made a comment on his stream,
didn't realize Nicholas would take it the wrong way, and was
like, "Hey, man. I hope we're good." Right? Is that not
Like when we when we saw Nicholas like going off in his Discord
about it.
You're on the You're on the right track.
I Like that's more what it seems like to me. Oh, I know Aiden
has some
What what's going on behind the scenes, Aiden? You're on all
these You're on all these You have all these Why can't you just
tell us? Um anything that I could leak, which I won't leak cuz
then nobody will tell me in private, you could just figure out
by watching this. Is it just Is it just Willy and Tommy crying
in private group chats about the fact that Chud told them or
what? No, I don't talk to I haven't spoken to Tommy in a long
time. I guarantee you Turkey Tom is not complaining about this.
And I guarantee you Turkey Tom would not Turkey Tom can handle
his [__] But then Aiden's saying Aiden's saying it's
obvious from what he's saying, so I'm just going by the the nuance
of what he's saying. between the lines. You have to ask yourself
some of the claims Tommy's making, how could he possibly know
them? Yes, exactly. Exactly, yes. Where's Tommy getting this
from?
Yes. Thank you.
And then you could figure out exactly what's going on here. Mhm.
Is it just Nick?
I'm not saying it's anyone. I'm saying figure out by watching
this. Well, that explains why I'm getting brought up. I don't
know why I'm included, okay? Tommy's never talked about me. Tommy's
never watched any of my content. Explains exactly why I'm being
brought up. Or he's just trying to get his talking
So, I think that's utterly ridiculous. Your relationship with
Nick DeOrio is your business as is everybody else that's in that
chat. Everybody. Wait, is he talking Did he just say actually
I don't think you should have a private conversation with Chud,
but also
Wait, what? He like advised Nick to not have a private conversation.
He's like also your relationship with Nicholas DiOrio is your
business. But you're like actually saying you want to [__] you,
Nicholas DiOrio. I suggested that he not talk about it privately.
Please let me listen to that again. He's just doing a lame-ass
temp- temperature check or you're just trying to get his talking
points.
So, I think that's utterly ridiculous. Your relationship with
Nick DiOrio is your business as is everybody else that's in that
chat. You could easily figure out what's happening here. I tell
you something, I'd be awful and then you can bet I told him that
that's
Sus. Yeah, that was me. And by the way DiOrio is just like actually
is saying that like freaking out thinking Chud's coming for his
neck or some [__]
Is that what's happening for real? That's really disappointing
if if that's actually how
fragile Nick's mindset is. Um I don't think that that is
what I'm getting at. That's what I'm getting from what Tommy's
saying. So, I I'm just like probing for whatever.
Got it. Got it. Do you have like a different interpretation,
Aiden, from what Tommy's saying? And then it's just that it's
just that. It's an interpretation. It's not me going off of some
like very explicit details that have been said to me in private,
but
based off of uh
Tommy is saying here is that it was probably treated like some
sort of backstab or betrayal. This was never stated to me explicitly,
um but uh that that that is contextually what I am engaging from
the situ- from the you know, the things I'm hearing right now.
Bro, that is just like
cuz he said you you Ethan Klein.
He is Ethan Klein. That's his job. It pays really well.
Why would he be ashamed? I think I I don't think he would agree.
Because and that's not me saying I don't agree. The point of
the matter is I actually haven't watched
any of his I watched parts of his streams, but it's what, 6 hours
he streams for? I don't I don't sit through those full things.
He's taking an overwhelmingly pro-Ethan stance and I don't blame
people who've seen as much as I have from thinking that, but
I think that that side disagrees obviously that he would be close
to Klein. Yeah, is that crazy to treat as a backstab? Dude, what?
No, I literally I would not have lost it
6 months knowing Chud if either of us treated
an outburst of that like a backstab. But I've tried to
I've tried to express this to to different sides of this issue
and I I
think that from an outsider perspective
or you could maybe potentially look at this is like he's genuinely
criticizing
Um I I don't or genuinely take some sort of big issue with you,
but if you I feel like if you know like anything about Chud you
obviously would not take it that way and I don't even remember
his like criticism like being super harsh against Nick. I think
he could some of the things Chud said like, yeah, it's just banter
like sarcastically could be interpreted as I'm being completely
serious, but I don't think if you any context that's obviously
not like the case that he put up. Hold on. That's also Chud's
position.
Like it's it's but it's like he's laughing about it. It is banter,
but it is also Chud's position. it is, but I but I think the
joke with him sarcastically saying it is like he's totally like
being like a
hammering it in.
Like like inflammatory inflammatory He's obviously he acknowledges
he's being inflammatory. Yeah. Yeah.
It was about the Augie stuff? Oh, yeah. I think Chud
Chud was just going off a little too much about Augie and Connor
running a show on a really stupid point. That was a stupid I
I totally disagree with Chud on that, but also that's like I
feel like that's like come
I don't I don't feel like that cut Augie and Connor particularly
deep. I feel like they're the people who are making a joke of
themselves so someone, you know, screenshots but it's like, "Okay."
But I mean they didn't seem to be bothered by what I watched
them talk about it. Yeah, and like I don't think Chud would ever
like not talk to them about it if they actually thought that
he was like really, you know, talking [__] or something.
He would he would just talk to them and be like, "Oh, yeah, I
see your perspective." I I assume.
Seems to be the case with all the other content he's done.
Chud has recently had that opinion though. I guess. Literally
anytime my name has come up from Chud on his stream it has been
like a super critical context or like a context of like banter
or whatever the But like any time to stream, Aiden's quit streaming,
Aiden totally [__] up that conversation.
Yeah, I don't know how many times I've heard him you say something
nice or him say something nice about you. Like I It's the same
for me.
Like I I played games with him and [__] Black Ops
with you and stuff, right?
Yeah, we're Yeah, we're I like Chud. I I I He hasn't said he
likes me, but I think we're cool or Um it's like a totally different
tone. It's a totally different tone than it would probably be
It's an abusive relationship.
Honestly, yeah, but I don't take it Like I Like I understand
what he's doing. I talk to him all the time on stream as well.
Um I don't really take it like super
Maybe it's cuz I'm used to getting [__] talked for
6 years, but like I don't take I don't I don't really take it
like that. Um it only gets like a huge deal. I know we're like
in a community where like the audience loves being inflammatory
and you're going to take genuine criticisms and maybe up the
passion more than how passionate you actually would be, but these
genuine the criticisms themselves are true, your actual beliefs.
I don't like I don't think it's like really a huge deal at all.
Chad says he likes me the same way Cenk Uygur says he loves Dan,
okay? That's it's like totally
It's like excessively signaling that you mean the opposite to
your audience. It's very clear.
I'm not signaling so I do like Dan. I do like Dan. Uh, okay.
Yeah. Just like that. It's exactly like that. It's [__]
up when Chad says it. As a on a like personal personality level,
I like Dan.
You know what? I I don't like Dan's
I'm going to make Chad state that he likes me. You're right,
chatter.
That'll go really well, yeah.
I need you to go live and talk about
Do a stream dedicated to me. do it on Twitter. Do it on Twitter.
Rude.
Begging for ChildLogic's approval. If you if you literally tell
him that like we we can't be friends anymore unless you do a
a live stream like talking about how much you like me as a I
will retweet that immediately. I
Just say He's not He's going to He's not going to get what we've
just talked about. So, he's going to see that and he's going
to think I've like lost my mind or That'll be even funnier.
My expense, though.
hm. Anyway, okay, we're back to the Tommy video. Yeah, yeah.
Getting the derail. Let me I'll roll it back about 20 seconds
here so we can get the context. trying to get his talking points.
So, I think that's utterly ridiculous. What does that mean trying
to get his talking points? I don't Let me not know. I have no
idea. Like is it Oh, you you You like hey, I'm just around cuz
you want Nicholas to like justify say like what he believes about
this so you could use it to criticize him further maybe? I that's
basically that's what I would fill in there but I don't know.
I mean well what would Okay, imagine that was happening. What
would be the problem with that? Um What would be the problem
with that? Uh that if you were using it explicitly to attack
him under the guise of friendship, hey let's work it out that
that would be sneaky. Oh sure. Well I suppose if it was like
under the guy I I I guess if you're like
deceptive about it in some way. But if you're like just asking
them, okay, what do you actually believe about this, you know,
and you still have criticism about it. The idea that you go into
them and asking them for their beliefs and then taking that and
being like, okay, well I know what they believe and I still have
disagreements with them. These are my disagreements. What like
what would be the that doesn't seem that there would be any any
issue there, right?
Uh no.
I don't think I don't think Nick would even remotely entertain
that conversation though.
I feel like the only conversation he'd really entertain there
is like, hey, didn't mean to hurt your feelings. Um didn't mean
to like or actually that might not even work. Might be something
like Hey, didn't mean to uh I hate to interrupt you but I was
trying to say something. Yeah.
It'd have to be something like that. Didn't mean to talk to you.
It kind of blew up more than I thought or something. I think
that would work.
Your relationship with Nick Diiorio is your business as is everybody
else that's in that chat. Everybody. But I tell you something.
I'd be awful and then you can bet I told him that that's
sus. Yeah, that was me. And by the way, don't think don't know
all the names. I'm not the only one and it's not
Not at all. I can tie the Kinetic Kel thing to just after I got
$5,000 from Musty.
But this is awful.
That's the part we're waiting for, man. He's a Does Musty not
want to oil an ephebophile or is that is what I'm
Well, no. I don't even think Mustie dropped him after that. I
think he just thinks that I don't know either the Mustie donation
was the
green light to take him out or I I I literally don't know what
he thinks is
You think But he I think he times together.
I think he's mad or No, I think he thinks the everyone was mad
that like Mustie cuz after So, my understanding is you made fun
of him cuz he was going to quit streaming over the internet stuff,
right? So, then in his mind and I know this is like totally ridiculous.
This isn't a defense. But in his mind, he's thinking, "Okay.
Well, um
they they must like they want to see me fail. And then Mustie
donates, thus extending his streaming career. And then he thinks,
"Okay, now the reason they're all in one big conspiracy against
me is because my streaming career has been extended because Mustie
gave me that money to support it. So, now they're going to try
and take take it down." When I said he was quitting streaming
over the internet stuff, that was just be I was
He posted a video saying he was going to quit stream He possibly
couldn't stream any longer. The show was going to end over the
internet stuff. It seemed obvious to me he was just like being
like dramatic. So, I was just mocking him for
That wasn't like I didn't genuinely think he was going to quit
streaming over the internet stuff at that point anyway even cuz
it's like what you You're moving into this house. You just bought
this house. And your internet would be so bad and you can't find
any solution for it that you're not going to be able to stream
for like the foreseeable years. Cuz he was talking about like
not having to wait for wire to be put in in like 3 years or something
like this. So, I know that's kind of So, I was just mocking at
that point. So, the idea that then it's, "Oh, no. We're going
to really kill the streaming career now." It's like you've just
bought into the troll at that point to be honest. Like that
You actually just do believe you're
gangstalked. Totally gangstalked. Um
Man, I It sucks that he
I I don't understand like I I feel like
I've gotten the entire vibe that like Spicy hates Tommy C and
has hated Tommy C for a long time and that Chud like
just he can't control any of that,
Like I I've never once gotten the impression that Chud has any
problem with Tommy C at all. So the idea that he's like added
Chud to the conspiracy is very bizarre to me. You know what I
mean? Like I I could say oh yeah, I think I think Spicy hates
him. I think you hate him or have hated him, right? But I don't
think I'd ever say like Chud hates him or was like trying to
get him over or anything like
I don't know. That's That's where it gets weird and conspiratorial.
Well, haven't you been listening to Tommy? That's the point to
Jay's talk. He's waiting for his chance. He uses Spicy's chat
as an outlet. Yeah.
Chud just makes fun of the show.
Chud doesn't even talk in Spicy chat. He just talks in there.
That's what you think. That's what you think. He talks in there
like once a week.
Yeah, he's he speaks in there like once a week. What are we doing
here? From
Maybe he's started typing more.
Yeah, maybe he's back to typing more in the Discord or something.
Yeah. I thought he was gone for a while.
Yeah, I know. You know what? You know what? You've convinced
me, Aiden. I think Chud has been trying to actually gang stalk
Tommy and ruin his career. He's waiting for his moment. True.
So true. Thank you. And all of the sudden, I'm getting I'm getting
grilled on that channel and I see what's going on. I'm like I
see the thumbnail that comes out. I'm like oh, I know what happens
here. I've seen that before. OH, I'M SORRY. MY MY THUMBNAIL GUY
MADE IT. I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO CONTROL OF IT. WELL, I'LL TELL
YOU SOMETHING. So what you [__] You're still a legend.
You're still a legend. I started I use this excuse. I don't actually
own the channel that posts most of my content that gets onto
YouTube. So I actually can use this excuse. I don't control anything
Royal does. I mean, it's just another suck it up, man, moment.
Like it it's thumbnails. What do you expect? Yeah. Yeah. According
to Shad, he's just gotten like People complain about like come
to him about their complaints for the thumbnails like several
times, and it's just public knowledge that it's just DK, like
I don't understand. Like What What was even the contents of the
thumbnail he's referring to?
Or implied he was a sack vest or something. Laugh about it.
video to the um Dude, the Tekton thumbnail was pretty legendary,
too. Damn. Damn. Dude, these liberals are offended by
Damn. What a thumbnail.
Is Tommy C here? No, this is a second channel video.
That's funny, though. You sound out of breath. I'm angry. Okay.
I think it was probably a second channel video. Supposed to be
made
Uh 12 hours of Hunter Avallone's failing marriage to fall asleep,
dude.
Well, that's legendary. I didn't see that. Yeah, exactly. It's
drama. I actually got the drama.
Commentary just bullied Tommy C into
I'm done mooching off my wife. I quit. I hope he bought Is this
the one he's talking about? I think this this has to be the second
one.
I don't know. Shad C or Shad covers Tommy C announcing his retirement
at the hands of the endless brutal harassment and bullying from
Queenman. Now, that is that will be the thumbnail.
Done mooching off my wife. I quit.
I hope he bought something pretty. Uh okay. All right.
Nick would have a problem. The thing is you and me aren't close
enough to be give a right. Me and Nick would have a problem if
he tried to make me out to be some kind of loser or like that.
But, here's the thing. One of the reasons I didn't [__]
about it because you made it abundantly clear that you're a credit
Oh, it is cuz of the mooching off the wife thing, then. Yeah,
dude. Yeah.
Well, that actually bit You do mooch off your Well, if you admit
you mooch off your wife, you stupid old bastard. Dude, what is
this guy saying? He does it for his wife. He's a breadwinner.
What does his wife do?
I don't know. She's like rich. And he talks about how she's a
rich German woman. He always talks about this. And he does his
dog [__] internet show for 3 hours every 4 days.
And sits around drinking all the time. Like he's a loser mooch.
Yeah, it sounds like Tommy Z 1. Damn. Did he win?
What an awesome guy.
Every right to be a critic. I just don't You're jealous. I should
watch this I should watch this carp posting video. True. I think
you're a very good friend. I think you're looking for the day
I think there's I think you're using Cenk and all those guys
to kind of get a goal into the one moment you say, "Yeah, Nick
really really he's a sweeper this time. He's a really a fighter
this time." He tried it with Willie Mack and you're all ready
to come down on him. I remember when you started your stream.
really what I'm complaining about? Exactly. That's what I was
going to say. Like what what is the what is the [__]
problem? Like if if Chud said one time, "Oh yeah, I think Nick
swept on this. I think Nick's totally wrong here. I think he
did sweep on this. I think he only did it to make this look look
less less bad than it was." What would be the problem if that
was said? Why would that be such a big deal?
Um because Chud's going to try to make a play for Nick's audience
and totally [__] Nick over. Okay. Okay. It's like
I I don't even think that's like how audiences work online, to
be honest. That's not true. Well, hold on. Hold on. It's not
unless there's like some amount of truth to it and you can make
Nick kind of lose his mind over Well, yeah. Yes, but then that's
self-inflicting. But that's not what you do to your friends.
That's not what you do to your You don't do that to your friends.
Why would you You can only do No, but you can only do that [__]
to yourself. You can literally only do that [__]
to yourself. A little bit, but sure. All right. birthday party.
Right? And you're all ready to go hard on Willie Mack until Nick
tweeted about it.
And said that Willie did a great job after a completely unfair
debate situation, the kind of debates that I will never be involved
with. What do you mean unfair? Unfair argue?
He's talking about arguing. No, no, no, no, no, he's talking
about Queen of Stream. Oh, he came in I wasn't like trying to
like [__] with Willy Mac. I joined that I joined
that stream to be like, "Hey, Kelly's making like a really reasonable
point." And then I made my point and then he agreed and then
I was like, "Wait, you also didn't put in like this other stuff?"
And I I wasn't like prepared to argue. I wasn't trying to argue
with them. I was like Sorry, I wasn't there to like try to come
over or something. I was like, "Oh, this seems important." I
hadn't even like written out or or thought about how to formulate
any of those arguments. Just like on the fly talking. I don't
know why I don't know why that seems is like Oh, it's like [__]
I offered to talk to Nick about it, too. God, I don't know.
I can close riots cuz people didn't drop out once Nick tweeted
and said it wasn't a big deal.
I guess so. you, dad. So, Chum, if I don't know if this is jealousy,
I don't know if you're a rat, I don't know if you're audience
captured, I don't know any of that stuff. Tell you truth, don't
really want to know because I'm going to treat you like a rat
no matter what and I'll just get out of your life and have nothing
to do with you. Now, I haven't heard from you in 6 months, so
you can't do this whole thing I'm stabbing you in the back. No,
I'm not. I haven't heard from you. I've no Did Chum react to
this? Oh, no, it's 6 hours ago. Oh, good. He said he's
Goodbye. He's going to talk to Chum He said he won't. He said
he won't react to it. He's being spicy? Hold on. Wait, hold on.
Hold on. he's going to talk about it, but he won't react to it
cuz he's cuz he's scared of Tommy C. Oh, what in the world is
happening here?
When he starts talking about it and doesn't watch it, please
get your broom emojis out. Yep, yep. We brigade in Chum's chat.
Spam brigade.
Think Chum's sweeping? He's trying to take over his audience?
Let's see here. Yeah, I'm coming for his audience right
Let's see here. Let's see what he was
Yeah, yeah, ban. Don't pull this up. You're going to get swatted
up. Oh, right. I forgot you're not supposed to do that. You're
about to get banned. Hold on. Wait, how can I cover it? I can
cover it by like saying it to him, right? I don't know. I don't
know.
Just read out the relevant messages. Just read out the relevant
messages. Just read out the relevant messages. It'll be fine.
Nobody snitches you're good. I spoke to him last Okay, hold on.
Hold on. Hold His commentary civil war is total cancer. I sounds
like he's given up on his ape creek that he called personally.
Yeah, that he personally called that he said himself. That's
just bizarre. I don't know why he would do that. Kind of leaving
us all out in the cold.
I'm like the edge here. That's messed up. I don't know why Tommy
is so upset with me, lol. Spoke with him last December. The last
message I sent was that the criticism of Slasher's stuff was
overblown and he could look at my coverage and tell me if he
had issues. Dude, Tommy could call me whatever and I would talk
to him. He could even record the call if he thought I was going
to snake him. Release it. I don't care. On stream, whatever.
I don't care. Or Hold on. Somebody says,
Why does he think so mad right now?
It's true. Somebody said, I think they attribute a lot of what
viewers say or Queen Man or Queen Man to Chud probably. I don't
know. Very confusing though. Or people attribute what Queen Man
says to me because they think I am literally his father. I mean,
that is the case. That is the case.
Are you going to cover the Tommy video, Chud? It will be funny.
I won't watch it, but I will talk about it. Don't worry, mate.
You'll get some scraps for later. I just want to watch and laugh.
I'll be disavowing you and siding with Papa Guts. Us fat guys
got to stick together, says Chud. This is Queen Man and Chud
going back and forth. Queen Man says, "If I can sell out the
Jews, you can sell out fat people."
Let's go. Self-hating Jews unite. Aiden and Queen Man together
at last.
What are What are these messages?
That's all of the messages, okay? That's all of the messages.
No idea what's going on. All I know is uh our relationship changed
immediately after I got a really generation a generous Wait,
Queenman, do you or it's not Queenman. Aiden, do you use the
word goislop? Have you added that to your
I think I've used it a few times like ironically I'd refer to
like brain rot
Okay, perfect. That's exactly what we're looking for. Uh our
relationship All right. I feel like I feel like we're out of
my wheelhouse. Um I'm going to peace out. Thanks for hanging
out, Legacy. Thanks for talking me through the uh the cop calling
thing. Yeah, have a good one. Sorry. I I was doing a a totally
separate thing. I thought I was just listening to your stream
and then I realized I was on the stream and that's uh No worries.
Have a good one. Good night. All right, you too. Yep. Bye-bye.
What drugs Immediately sky taken, man.
Uh Legacy's awesome. Don't talk [__]
Wow, sweeping. The red pill. He's taking the red pill, Chud.
That guy That guy lives with Darius and he is not insane.
He after I got a really generation a generous donation from my
musty, that kept me up for like a month and a half so I can do
the show. And I think it's musty thing? That's right. Queenman
made me retired. And that's it. He got me, I guess. I don't know
why where that came from. Oh, wait a minute. That came from you.
Thanks for the support, buddy pal. Yeah, you're right. And so
yeah, I think you're being duped. Oh man, Chud pretended to be
this guy's friend. He lured He lured Tommy C into a call with
Queenman. Ended his career and then mocked Tommy C for getting
his career ended by Queenman.
This guy's making a pretty good point, to be honest. Pretty good
points. This is like lost. Can we Can you acknowledge that, Kenny,
that you totally lost?
What do you What do you mean totally lost? Like Well, because
you you have like literally defined it as anytime I I'm winning,
you're losing. So.
Yeah, they It's almost like they think that Jews are so superior
that they can actually act against the Jews interest and the
Jews will still be fine. So, they can be self-hating and superior
at the same time. It's really [__]
Dubious. Two-faced. And I smell the Even then, they did not self-hating.
It's so arrogant when you It loops back around to self-hating.
Who gets Dan Saltman to cover this chatter?
Did we
add Batman because of Queenman and Jay
Is this stuff I don't even Dude, WE HAVEN'T EVEN I HAVEN'T TALKED
TO YOU ON STREAM IN LIKE A week and a half. I What the [__]
going on?
This crazy [__] Anyway.
Um did Jay Stalk make any bets about how this would play out?
This stuff? No. I do have some bets closing that I'm probably
losing on recently though. I have like existential dread recently.
I think I have some bets closing that I don't know if they're
going to go well.
Adam Adam, who are we adding?
I think Dan Saltman.
Uh Dan's literally in the Discord and has permission to join
this channel if you wanted.
Dan isn't awake.
Uh I think it's like against his anything else contract to join
this Discord anymore though.
He technically He technically could though. Dan's in this Discord.
He's He could join this channel if you wanted to. No, I was obviously
Hey hey Dan, when you having an interview with Dan or something
then you say what when's that happening? Um I haven't followed
up with him yet. I was going to I was Yeah, is there a good
Sorry, what did you say? Nothing. Somebody asked if I paid Queenman
for a bet on Hassan. And I Okay, yeah.
He agreed to do an interview with me because he hates Sunday
so Um I haven't really figured out when or what I'm going to
do with that yet.
Sounds like I'll Sounds like it'll be good.
It'll go It'll go better than the uh one, right?
The Cameron What is your like Name your What is your criticism
with the Cameron interview? What is your criticism?
I can't have a criticism if I didn't watch it. You suck, dude.
Give the stream to Kenny, bro. Give the stream to Let Kenny take
over Day 1. I didn't watch any of the Cameron
That was before I was Good times. Good times. All right. All
principle. So, if it's jealousy, if it's whatever it is, you
know, good luck with that. Have a great time with this. But,
here's the thing. Jealousy never gets you anywhere. If you are
getting passed by Nick and other streamers, and they pass your
relevance level, do what I do. Congratulate them. Don't phony
call them out. You can certainly criticize um Ethan Klein. By
the way, I have been for months, and me and Nick have talked
about the differences without stirring
Don't criticize Nick's talking point. Make up your own.
Okay, now it's just like very explicit. Now it's incredibly explicit.
Oh, boy. Oh, this is the thinking they have, man. It's so crazy.
I would say Okay, It's actually I find this like despicable.
I find this personally despicable. I'm not going to lie. I find
it like actually kind of gross that there are commentary content
creators who make their living criticizing other people and stirring
up drama. And now it's like, "Oh, well, now now the Twitter accounts
are talking about me and saying bad things about me." It's like,
"Bro, who gives a What This is your job."
I will say I think um especially if you're friends, you should
have some positive position of your own to go with your uh like
negative position, your uh what do you call it? Oh, for sure.
For sure. You should have some constructive position to pair
with your deconstruction of their position, right? And they should
jive with each other. I think that's probably pretty important
if they're your friends. Otherwise, you're just sort of like
criticizing them to criticize. And you can do that, and that's
like funny content actually. It's really funny content to have
like just deconstructive opinions and to like tear somebody apart,
right? But you should if they're your friend, I think you should
do that. You should have like a an idea of what they should have
done instead or where the things went wrong, maybe. Something
along those lines.
I think I think that's you're their friend, not their debate
coach. I mean what is this?
I'm saying that like if you don't have any any actual investment
of your own and you're just criticizing them cuz you think they're
like being I don't know I don't know if they're your friend if
that like makes sense, right? Like oh, you're just invested in
like tearing them down.
Like it feels like you could have some positive position of your
own, and then it would feel different to that person, right?
Like you would have some investment to want to tear down their
opinion. Or maybe maybe you don't even need like a Like you need
something though, right? To say like I'm not just I'm not just
criticizing you cuz you're like making logical errors or something.
I like I think there's some downside here, and this is what I
think the world should be like anyway. Yeah. Say that.
Yeah, yeah. never that definitive on anything. You're a fence
rider. And that comes off as being fair. It's not. I think it's
fake. I think you're a phony friend. I think you're a phony friend
and
what you did to get Nick's attention and how he helped you, and
the other guys too, and the whole loser commentary community,
they've been very very very good for you. Unbelievably
Let's not forget that you got catfished by a 17-year-old.
Can we say stolen my talking point here? He stolen my talking
point. I I've been saying
Oh.
It was a little boy. You love to see it.
What did try to say about Nick
Is there like his eating tags?
Yeah, now Tommy's like actually you are
And and Chud is still like willing to work things out and not
going to cover Like I don't understand that. I don't understand.
Why would you not cover this? Because he's still friends with
Nick and Tommy's just acting on behalf of Nick. If you kill one
of Nick's pets, he gets quite upset. I'm still I'm still friends
with Nick. I would no problem saying this is like
Yeah, but you're not directly criticizing Nick on your stream.
go, "Hey Nicholas De Orio, I'm calling you out." and then Nick
kind of had his I literally watched and made fun of his I actually
I actually I actually I actually agree with J Soogz narrative
that he's been here. I think this is a great narrative. Chode
is Chode is kissing the ring, kissing the Don's ring. That's
why he's not covering this today. That's why he's not watching
this on stream today cuz he's desperately groveling, kissing
the Don's ring. So, Chode wants to prove that he's not desperately
groveling and kissing the Don's ring, but I think he needs to
watch this today on his live stream. If he doesn't cover it,
he's he's just as bad as the rest of us. It's what we call like
behavior. I didn't say any of those things. That's just Queen
Miss narrative that he made up. I don't know where so
you guys go off with your whole thing there. Thank you. I'm just
saying. No. No. That's not what I'm saying. Chode has 24 hours
to cover it or we'll all take the position that he was in fact
a
I do love Dude, it's so awesome that Tommy does the classic,
okay? Elon Musk just did this. Oh, you're going to be a piece
of [__] to me? Well, actually you the whole time.
Even when we were friends, you were actually a It doesn't make
sense. I didn't care about it when you were being nice to me,
but now
oh boy, it's a problem now.
Oh my god. Myself.
Look the other way, thought it was [__] up and
gave you the best. And you go, "I couldn't believe I was Hey,
he said look the other way.
Oh, what is he doing? Shut up. that you got catfished by a 17-year-old
I'm going to listen to it all again. And everybody, including
myself, looked the other way, thought it was up, and
gave you the best of your Dude, that's actually [__]
insane. Yeah, why would you say this? Why would you say this?
awful for my career THAT I THOUGHT YOU WERE A but I let it go.
I looked the other way. leave it there. Nothing to explain
Oh, my favor covering it. Oh, that's so good. By covering them
up we're doing you a favor. He should have been nice to us. Okay.
Dude. Okay, buddy. Oh, my god.
Huh, what the I couldn't believe I was saying this. I was on
the phone this guy's the best guy I've seen in many years. I
love his show. I love calling in. Do you ever see me calling
in every any other shows like that? Never. Never. Cuz I love
it. And then all of a sudden I get a donation and I'm a a b I'm
they're entertaining me being a pest and they're entertaining
the whole entire time. He can't confirm this to be true. Stop
bringing up the musty donation. Like you have actual proof, that's
why.
He's like this and that. This is all speculation and he's going
off like it's fact.
particularly remember, but and he did shut it down in fairness,
but it just seemed like they're just waiting. I've seen it continue.
I've seen it continue with Willie. I've seen it continue with
Nick and they're just trying to nail him on Mr. Lips. Well, my
recommendation Tom Augie have nothing to do whether I don't know
if Chud's really doing this or not. I don't know if he's doing
this or not. Have nothing to do with him because you can't trust
him. Whether he's ordering audience capture or being a rat, I
don't know which. Then
he's not somebody to trust. And believe me, nothing Batman I'm
saying is new because nobody's been on. And this is what's being
talked about behind the scenes. Yes, Chud. That's it. I don't
know if you're sitting there giggling saying we got him, we're
fooling them, we got a perfect system here. Nobody I actually
don't know. Like if I were if I were Nicholas, let's say, I actually
would hate this. Why are you taking like my personal rantings
from behind the scenes and just making it extremely clear that
this is what I'm saying to you. Why would you just like actually
reiterate this like one-to-one?
I that would be so annoying.
Nobody They didn't want to fight because they're actually brain
dead. I don't I don't know why you do it. because he liked you.
They didn't want to alienate Nick and um look, you got to deal
with your relationships. Now you know where I stand because one
of the biggest reasons I'm doing this is because I want everybody
to know where I stand. I want you to know and everybody else.
I don't trust you. I think you're kind of a weird guy and I don't
think you're that great at debating either. So if you want to
get into this debate
Okay, not a great debater is a fair point but weird guy from
what? Is he's a Is he's a [__] head of little boys?
That's crazy.
I love that he saved that for last. I don't think you're that
debater. Should start with that.
And worst of all, sir, you are a terrible interlocutor. I was
saying Yeah, yeah, child, when you were on that debate panel
and you're like those two libertarians, you kept calling them
I don't think you really made very good arguments. It's like
dude When was child ever going like you're the best debater around?
Like it's so What a stupid thing to say.
My goodness. Dude, this is a this is a wild stream. I don't or
yeah, it's a stream, right? Yeah, he's got a chat. Yeah. I don't
know why you do this. great at debating either. If you want to
get into this debate stuff, I think it's just You just ride the
waves. You're typically you're kind of like the English guys.
I just you look a little different, you sound a little different,
you're a little better spoken than the English guys we dealt
with in 2016 and 2017.
Anyway, back to the history. And I don't know why you want to
get off the wheel like this. All about Alex at the end of the
day. Yes, everything about No, it's about why don't you guys
they should start calling out angle phobia as much as they call
out anti-semitic.
He's mocked your accents repeatedly. He's like British people
just like to take it up the ass.
Why isn't this guy just like learn to speak the language he's
in countries living in before he starts to look at me out, you
know, other countries. You're different and you're a little better
spoken than the English guys we dealt with in 2016 and 2017.
I thought he was going to say 1776.
I don't know why you want to get him off the The Oreo wave. Maybe
it's cuz he's pulling 7,000. Whatever.
You certainly don't have to support Ethan Klein. The guy is nuts.
I completely agree with you on that. Like what does he think
about you getting off the The Oreo wave? Who thinks like this?
Yeah, for real. I It's It's bizarre. Like uh
It's like mafia. It's honestly like when people call it a cabal.
Like this is literally what a cabal would do, right? It's like
not even remotely in that category. I popularized that term.
Thank you, Aiden, for popularizing the term. Okay. You can't
criticize it without alienating Nick or creating drama. You can
do it. You did a great job, Aiden, popularizing that term. It
is super accurate. Thank you. I've been doing it for months.
I said Ethan was wrong about I'm trying to see if Aiden will,
you know, come out of his shell a little bit if we give him positive
reinforcement instead of just trashing him all the time. Pressuring
iDubbbz. And I took it back when I realized I think it will work
out. And I also said from the very beginning that Ethan asked
for this [__] because he got in bed with a bunch
of [__] lunatic
So, there you go. Have I ever Okay. Wait. Lunatic communist.
Wait. I wasn't watching the end. Wait. I was I was thinking of
something else. I was saying I said Ethan was wrong about pressurizing
iDubbbz. And I took it back when I realized Ethan was right.
And I also said from the very beginning that Ethan asked for
this [__] because he got in bed with a bunch of [__]
lunatic
So, there you go. Now you know where I stand. and for all the
other you know malcontents that these these weirdos like this
virtue signaling white knight [__] from gay sock
demand look no one has to debate.
WHAT THE [__] NO ONE HAS TO DEBATE YOU.
I DIDN'T SAY WHAT THE [__] did I say to
I've never said somebody had to dude it's not my fault that Nick
cancelled after accepting twice to talk to me. IT WAS NEVER A
DEBATE.
I WASN'T NEVER GOING TO GO AFTER HIM
What what the [__] this? I I think I think if you
criticize people on the internet you should absolutely be willing
to face at least reasonable
I think the idea that you just totally shut off is completely
gay and cowardly and embarrassing for someone that is talking
crazy [__] about people
The the thing is whether I'm sympathetic to you but I I made
this criticism for positioning yourself
up you shouldn't be able to run like any You're you're breaking
up you can't
Sorry I I
Can you hear me now? I was I said this for Cameron. I said this
for Cameron. I think that if you're going to position yourself
as like the next content you should be able to you have like
probably some sort of obligation to face criticism against you
and he only wanted to go people soft balling him but like I can
understand
being good or bad at a debate doesn't affect like how correct
you are on an issue because some people are just not rhetorically
gifted or fast paced others are and you're not good at debating
like I can be sympathetic to you not wanting to do it even if
I don't think that's like necessarily running
but you should be facing that criticism in some as opposed to
just not addressing it at all which seems to be what he did with
the slasher.
I don't know I mean he talked to Creamer over the slasher thing.
I I think well I don't think it was about the slasher a Creamer
ambushed him? Came up in passing but I didn't think it was really
about searching it. But um the
I I I feel like
Yeah, you shouldn't have to like go into a super contentious
debate. But I feel like if you can't talk through with
why you have the take you have, that's a problem. If you and
if you're refusing to do that at all, that's really shameful.
Yes. Yeah. I think you guys are being way too charitable. You
I don't think he thinks
I don't think he like actually thinks these points uh gets a
vibe and then he just says whatever the top of his head. There's
like no thinking.
Dude, I'm just I didn't realize how much this guy had in common
with me. Hold on. Hold on. Scum of the feed, you understand that
it's not about them being political streamers, they're commentary
streamers. They are critics by nature. And if you have critiques
of other people, but you won't hear critiques of yourself, you're
just like a like a shallow, fragile [__] right? That's
the point. Like you should if you have critiques, if you talk
[__] about other people, if you spend a lot of time
nuking other people, you should be willing to listen to criticisms
and respond a little bit. Like you if you feel like they're totally
bad faith, you don't have to respond, right?
But if you if there's like something you a bad or something like
that. Like the the thing with Tommy is he responds to things
he has no reason to respond to. Why would you even mention that
X6 edited to make it sound like he, you know, sent Cal pics of
14. It's so obviously edited and nobody was taking it seriously.
I think anybody actually took that video seriously.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but I don't think that's the case. And
Tommy decided to pull up on his stream and and make it a big
thing see it about it. So then of course it's going to get posted
more. Yeah, you've just given all these just like exactly what
they wanted. You've just thrown them the red meat.
You always have a couple of because this is like there are so
many artists here, you always do have
anybody anyone substantial where it's worth addressing. That's
the mistake I made when I covered the document written
I don't know what the document is. I'm unaware, so I I cannot
comment. The document Queen and covered it and said I was guilty
for about an hour.
I got to keep Yeah, yeah, there there there's some insult document
written about him by by by an account. A 23 year who we found
out was like a 23 year old
That's actually going to A 23 year old
The 23 year old man was pretending to be a 16 No, you're cutting
out a 16 year old man, girl? A A The The 23 year old man was
pretending to be a 16
from your content. All right, hold on. I'm backing I'm backing
this up just a little bit here. weirdos like this virtue signaling
white knight gay stalker man. Look, no one has to debate you.
No one has to debate you. Now Now, what you could do is just
try to push up everything the Chud from your content and see
if he picks a
Because that's what it looks like to me. Don't know if it is.
Doesn't matter. Where did I ever I've never told this to take
a side.
I think the only time I mentioned Chud about any content like
recently is I told him I was like, "Here's the Pazookas guy.
Here's Tekton commenting on his videos obsessively."
I think that's like the last time I talked to him. I I don't
talk to this guy. I never tell him to look at my content, take
my side. What the [__] But it looks
to me. It looks like a bunch of fake
Nick Man, did you like that?
You You were like You were the smart Well, the only thing I think
like not to leak, but I I like I've talked about this before.
When when I had the debate with Willy Mac or whatever, Chud came
to me was like, "Hey, I just want to like make sure everything's
cool." I think it was around this time. He's like, "I just want
to make sure there's like a truce and everything's cool." And
I was like, "Yeah, I won't talk shit." And then like Willy Mac
just kept talking on Twitter for like weeks after that. I I totally
backed off.
But if if they thought that was Chud taking my side, um I felt
like Chud negotiated like a ceasefire and then they just kept
shooting and I didn't do
Cuz I told them I would not.
although that might have been with me and Nick at a different
point. That might have been around the air that I tweet. I can't
remember now. It could have been around the air that I tweet
and then maybe the Willie Mac thing doesn't apply.
But um any case, I was like I wasn't trying to go hard on these
people at all. No one for that. Now, he can answer all these
allegations or my questions and and what have you on his own
phone. Not that it Not that it matters a whole bunch, but and
I will move on. I promise you. If he wants to come out back at
me, I'll be happy to answer him. But I tell you what, if you
just say I'm and and conspiracy theories, you're going to have
to deal with one of two things. A, that's going to leave an empty
taste in your audience's mouth. And B, I'm not THE ONLY ONE.
OH, HE ACTUALLY BASICALLY Hold on. Did he throw down the gauntlet
and Chud is still going to run? Did he throw down the gauntlet
like you literally can't respond to me? You can't just You can't
just dismiss me? You have to actually respond? And Chud is going
to not respond? He's not going to watch and respond directly?
is running Chud is running from Tommy C. I think he just threw
down Did he not Am I mishearing that? say I'm and and conspiracy
Hold on. Hold on. and I will move on. I promise you. If he wants
to come out back at me, I'll be happy to answer him. But I tell
you what, if you just say I'm and and conspiracy theories, you're
going to have to deal with one of two things. A, that's going
to leave an empty taste in your audience's mouth. And B, I'm
not the
Have a good day. Have a good day. only one. We got three more
minutes. Yeah, this is the whole like oh Turkey Tom doesn't talk
to you. Nick doesn't talk to you. All these guys. I guess.
But no, he didn't quite say that.
Yeah, he He said if you're going to call me a I feel like Chud's
just going to respond directly.
I don't know. Boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom next scene. Wow, wow, we were Yeah. That was that was
something.
There you go.
Stick around. That's the way I feel. Wait a minute, look at Chud's
response. Twice it. Bye. Good luck. Hey, I'm retired. It don't
matter. I say what the [__] I like, right?
There you go.
Yes, it's sweeping so dedicated and I post your stream directing
Tommy C. All right, let's watch this. things for [__]
playing content. Perhaps you'll crack 100 viewers saying if you
keep endlessly fixating on [__] you drop at me.
That's Tommy. Can I get raped? Tommy, what do you have to say
to this?
That was [__] up. Aiden breaks 100 viewers all the
time, doesn't he? On on average. I haven't got below 100 in a
long time.
What is Chud saying here?
He's calling up Why would Tommy C Yeah, exactly. He's wrong anyway.
People love him talking about this Tommy C video. That'd be That'd
be entertaining as [__] People loads of people think
it's funny. This guy is straight up came out and called Chud
a snake like a dishonest Saying he's going back on defending
dirty dealing.
He's saying he's a
He was totally looking the way. Why wouldn't Chud cover this?
This is perfect content.
Chud is running cuz he knows Tommy C is right. He was in 17-year-old
boys. God, you know what? I was like willing to look the other
way, but now if Chud runs, I'm going to have to also agree with
Tommy C, okay? I'll defend a who stands on business, but one
who runs away from Tommy C, never. Never.
Now, thankfully for me, I have He turned on the Adam's video.
I don't know why he left the rest of this in. Is there anything
else here?
I George, you have this video already recorded. This is just
a little addendum. I think an addendum is something you put at
the end. But this is a pre-dendum. I'm throwing in a little pre-dendum.
Something that I've been struggling with for a long time on YouTube
is concern trolling. The thing that I really struggle with is
not identifying concern trolling. The difficult part of identifying
last video
It's all just concern trolling, man. I'm sure Batman I'm sure
Chud has defended
several times before, but I'm sorry this this Ooh, I have to
point out that I've seen Chud defend you at several points though,
Tommy. This is a little confusing. So this is a little confusing.
This this behavior is Yes, he has. When it's absolutely
ridiculous and he doesn't have the position to do it, he does
it. I've defended Chud before if you remember. If you know that
Batman. I've done it before myself, right? I've even done it
when I'm suspicious of it. By the way, I'll continue to do it,
too. I'm just telling you I don't trust that guy. I think it
I'm calling out you, NICK DI OREO. SINCE WHEN ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT THE ADL? NEVER.
OH, I'M SORRY, NICK. It I just kind of came out that way. That's
what I heard Sorry, if somebody is, you know, doing [__]
and you know, you can argue you can argue he shouldn't start
working directly with the ADL, but the ADL is serving Ethan's
interests and Ethan is, you know, talking directly to people
who are getting the ADL to serve his exact interest, right? And
so when you only criticize the people who are going against that,
right? You only attack those other people
and you never ever provide like a, you know, a measured criticism
back towards Ethan. You You make the exact same arguments the
whole way down.
When after I got off the one the guy I didn't know called Queenman.
Oh, I'm sorry. Didn't know it was going to go that way. No, I
was being hard rangled. And how many times can this
If you look at the Bowblax thing, which by the way nobody believes,
and you look at the thing with the Turkey Tom and the way he
was positioning himself when he knew damn well this is going
to come out, it's sus. Is it proof? No. Can I get like the anime
I want anime Chud logic, okay? Pushing up the glasses. He is
the glass push upper from every anime, okay? The strategist.
He's sitting there moving chess pieces around. Yes, now I will
leak Now I will
Bowblax in a dress. Now I'll press Turkey Tom. Now, I'll set
Queen Mary on Tommy C. All the All the meanwhile, he's got a
very rotund king on the other side of the board that he's looking
to capture, okay? It's all been wasn't that it was it was New
Year's. He probably had a beer and uh just fell off of my bike.
He was wearing a dress. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No no
way. It was just him.
He's just a strategist. He's sitting there 180 IQ giga [__]
uh Yakubian brain, okay? He's sitting here and he's putting it
all together. He's planning the downfall start to finish, okay?
He's now just watching it play out. He set the table and he's
watching it play out, okay? Yeah, and crazy. he was so smart
but then he must have donated and he got so angry he started
revealing his he started explicitly revealing that he was hated
Tommy C. $5,000.
We have to move the plan forward.
This is ridiculous.
Oh, but it's enough for me to say sayonara. Wow.
Damn. Well, unfortunately, Chud is just going to totally roll
over for that, so
Can we Can we get Tommy Tommy C in Chud's time slot, okay? Uh
he just took his time slot from him. Chud, you got to move. Whatever
Whatever Tommy C streams, okay? That's That's your new time slot.
Tommy Tommy just took it.
Unless you respond.
I think he's not going to watch this. It's fine. Okay. All right,
I think that's it for the stream, guys. I think we Wait, hold
on. Is it? I think I added all the time, right? Yeah, that seems
about right. I think we go 9 hours here. I think I had 9 hours
on the stream. Yeah, 9 hours and 36. We did it all. Yeah, we
farmed Tommy for 2 hours, yeah. We farmed him. Sean Maloney,
thank you very much for those 30 gifted at the end of the stream.
Massive. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. All right. What a great
stream. Thanks for being here, guys.
I'll be back tomorrow.
Yeah, thanks everybody else for joining in, Queen and Kenny,
Legacy, Aiden. Thank you guys for being here, and we'll we'll
see you guys tomorrow. Bye-bye.